and just to remind all the viewers here
about the format for this event well
first and foremost you have to be
international master none of this grand
master business and I am event only but
as the chest goes 75 minutes of 5+1
blitz 45 minutes of 3+1 blitz then 25
minutes of 1 minute with one second
increment bullet chest single
elimination winner advances we all know
how these brackets formats work and let
me ask you while we bring up the bracket
here what is it like since you've been a
participant in speeches championship
yeah what is it like playing in this
format for hours on that one thing which
immediately comes to my mind is that you
need stamina like you know you are
playing so much of blitz that eventually
when it comes to pull it you start to
you know lose your focus yeah and the
chances of making mistakes really high
so I think you need stamina you need to
be sharp throughout and it's not easy to
adjust immediately I remember that when
I came from five plus one to three plus
one and then pull it I lost my thread in
bullet in one match and I won nine games
in bullet so you know it can go either
way you can like win or lose in bullet I
think that's a very crucial part of the
match well I think it's a good time some
of the players this match because he's
been mentioned bullet and Tonya she
yourself said I'm not used to online
speeches whereas levy is very well-known
on streaming on Twitch you know his
Gotham chest
he plays a ton of blitz and bullet so
Tonya is a high rated classical player
between the two but what do you think
that means in terms of bullet can she
catch up with just you know a few games
in this mattress is she too far behind
in terms of experience I was checking it
like she's like 50 points higher than
classical but in chess comm rating
he never leve Rosman I don't know if I'm
pronouncing it Larry Rosen is right okay
he has like 300 points high area which
is not like a small gap so I think he's
pretty much used to this interface and
stuff and if in bullet you know if there
is a chance
Flagg he was go for it so I think he's
the favorite in the format too but you
know you never know but I think he has
more practice for it totally and well we
don't have to wait much longer to figure
out who the favor will be after the
games are going because we're starting
these games right now and did it
yesterday I was here with Daniel
narrowed its key we were cracking some
jokes but we did show a lot of respect
to the players because you know people
wonder what's the difference being I am
in a gym
well for starters only AIIMS are a lot
of play in this tournament but in a more
serious note these players dedicate
their lives to the game and I was saying
that in a single game of chess that it
these players could of course be either
of us and just in a game it's an over a
course of a match from the games
continue and you play a longer series of
events then that's where the difference
makes something known but I do agree to
some chess I give it to completely and I
think it'll be a close match at least in
the five plus one section and then okay
I don't know what it's a bit random
of course I'm really excited to see the
match yeah and I feel like this was a
big question mark math match for me
because I know levy online chess to play
some often but Tonya I haven't seen a
pledge compensated with her I watch her
do commentary and interviews and
Gibraltar and st. Louis and all these
events but I have not seen him play
online blitz pretty much ever and right
now she's totally even on the clock I
prefer White's position the knight on c6
in front of the pawn on c7 you'd prefer
that pawn to be on c5 so I already like
Tonya's positions first game
but what about you video you feeling why
does this [ __ ] or is it just me just one
second I'm I'm loading the game back to
them not dead yet
oh no worries yeah you know just get it
here join me for the fun gotham chess
and tonya s4s i got i got the game i got
the game so it was a Queen's Gambit
right yes it was but it's a Queen's
Gambit because there's a knight on c6
and a pawn on c7 right when you accept
that Queen's Gambit usually you want to
play it for c5 or b5
I think b3 is a bit soft you know I
think it has to go for like efore stuff
but in the last question it didn't work
because you have Bishop f3 and 94 right
ah look at you spying those Geum texts
they're not allowed here you haven't
gotten the memo Bishop f3 Bishop 3
Knight takes d4 and the point is there's
a push of H to check at the end when the
Queen captures on d4 the Queen will be
hanging look at you
get out here these are not just GM
tactics there's some super GM tactics I
don't think we really informed you what
your role was for the show but I'm here
I'm more serious
really nice nice I've never been accused
of being too nice it was the first time
for everything you prove it live in
front of all our viewers okay so he
played route d8 and now I'm expecting
something like 92 okay actually
practically when I look at the portion
it seems easier for black to play you
get this a 5 stuff so now you should
play Bishop g6 you should not exchange
so what leads you to believe that the
bishop shoots will remain on the board
for black it makes it easier right if
you think we should be to Queen e2 and
then you get roopd 1 9 c4 all kinds of
stuff right yep the griot
III think Bishop g6 makes sense do you
know make it a little bit harder to okay
he goes you take some this is what its
gonna happen video you actually use this
today you were gonna say something makes
sense and I'm going to agree with you
but it's not going to happen so just get
used to that we're in for a long ride
here and the players have played quite
solidly but I like what you said about
some of the play being a little bit too
soft because you know instead of going
for concrete ideas there's been a little
bit of slower approaches and we will see
that because the players are just
getting used to each other's styles but
we
look at the center here for white now
you've Eve 4 in d5 Knight coming to c4
regardless it's not so bad like it's not
so bad that mostly because their c6 now
right
you take in 96 Oh 96 you know whenever
I'm suggesting move and he plays the
exact opposite like I said that you you
clearly aren't super familiar with what
we're gonna have in store for us just
get used to that and they're gonna be
many surprising moves but so far I
really do believe this has been a very
solid game c6 is one of those committal
moves now of course you can't play it
because the night look happens with the
bishop and then Bishop 83 will follow
using that Bishop him to skewer the
Brooks but the essential point of black
is just saying I don't want to commit to
something where I'm not entirely sure of
the consequences and you and I both will
have this problem you know well we play
our blue it's games like that's a
decision you can't take back so maybe I
shouldn't go for it I should rush
another move but admit it
I must say I'm impressed with Tania's
time management thus far up 30 seconds
in the clock that's good buddy yeah
really good that's really good and you
know one of the important things in this
mattress is how you cope up with the
loss because it's so easy to go on tests
so if Tonya starts well I think she has
a better chance to you know in that
match so the first few games are really
important because going on tilt happens
to everyone even Magnus goes on till
sometimes yep I completely agree with
you now Knight a5 by the way looks the
really annoying move coming after that
b7 pawn this was a theme that we saw in
one button yesterday between like you
can just go Bishop b6 and the knight is
trapped on b7 if you take you so I'm
making good moves this is not okay just
let me make my one move to right you
don't see it happening I'm gonna take on
b7 so you're right that you can just go
Bishop e6 back and I have to go tonight
c4 and I see the point but I think sort
of trick you 95 Bishop d6 nicéphore and
you don't want to repeat you go Bishop
a7 then I had mission a3 getting your
work on that fate so I'm trying to trick
you vit it let it just sometimes you got
to make it seem like I can also compete
with you it's I know come on yeah you're
you're being too modest today I don't
know what happened to you
I'm just you know awed by you as my
co-commentator because yeah typically
I'm with Danny wrench and that's all I
need to say about that then I've been
with Danya who is an amazing player
superfast lightning quick has great
impressions but now I'm with you know
the cool calm collected video Gujarati
and I just have to show you that I
respect you I'm just letting you know
that out loud everybody heard that's the
first time I've ever said I respected my
co commentator on air Thank You Man
thank you and that's the last bit of
modesty and respect your gang so we're
gonna go the jokes now what do you think
about the c6 move because I just want to
scoop that off the board right away just
dc-6 I was thinking about the takes
Quincy 695 and don't you have Queen e6
in the end I mean like I don't like this
movie um III kind of messed up with the
coordination now I agree this night on
a3 is not very happy over here it takes
another move just to bring it back in
the game and now black is shown hey I'm
ready to chisel out your Center and
there's no good discovery exactly look
at pre moved so now I think what white
should do is take on f6 and play g3 as
soon as possible if the knight gets to
f4 it will be not good right because the
knight now attach the Queen the h3 pawn
the g2 square for the d3 square is very
important this position so I agree with
that econ at six
there's no one move here exactly exactly
this is the movement which I don't like
you're wasting a 20 seconds on the more
button I have six oh I mean I don't know
what's an alternative is there any
alternative actually there's I mean
Knight c7 looks ridiculous 93 93 94 last
night ever so night six of six is the
only woman she spent 40 seconds on that
move that's what's crazy
yeah that's were inexperienced really
rears its ugly head because when you
play blitz all the time that oh I have
to take on f6
and now I should figure out a move right
now she should not be spending another
ten plus ads at this point gg-go g3 yeah
g3 she's worried about Queen g5 is it
like getting do an Ida for ideas well
here it's happened but I do believe
after Queen g5 actually that it's pretty
annoying
yeah just you know what I like to do
when my opponent gets loan time like
this is one minute and I have a 1-minute
lead I start playing fast to put even
more pressure you know right
that's really and he goes Quincy file
that's good that's good
he Frank - well this this is not allowed
why do you keep saying that blink code
or suggesting good news is not enough
you clearly did not get the memo for
this event like why do you think that
Danny organized this event it's so the
other players will not make good moves
he'll make some good moves he'll win the
event and he's the champion of something
right you know it's just what it is and
I like she like his rookie one move and
a tribe is a great decision by levy but
night of for a move a good living it by
queen g4 and then White's know what
takes and then there's you know 92 93
that's a very annoying I don't like that
five to be honest you don't like h1h
four-year what's wrong with this
decision I'd seafood
the problem is night on g6 how do you
get it now the night is fine there don't
you be so judgmental about this night no
I agree with you it as part three
squares away from a night just totally
dominates it so you are correct and
earlier night of four was a way to
activate the piece because h4 may ruin
White's pawn structure a little bit and
there's h4 is played but it's not that
big a deal at a queen chief or she's
taking advantage this night but if you
take on g3 FG and don't you have rook
did too well I think we're gonna be on
g3 take with the Queen on g3 oh no no
come on Queen f6 Knight f4 and yeah but
rook t2 is is too bad you know if I
you're absolutely right we'll teach you
check then I'm trying to take on d2 and
take your a to Monica she has to win she
dreams white lost the thread like after
Bishop III all the nerves you know the
position kept getting worse but I don't
think it is that bad I agree with you
that she's lost a threat but once this
Knight comes from c40 III then there's
d5 and f5 first night what if what if
windage finds now like a taking on d1
getting a temple and queen g4 back
probably have a necessity now I'm not
saying I like it but Queen g4 feels like
the quick move is to try straight Queens
and literally move on
to not get worse there it is in it 694
yeah you're right it's not as bad as it
looks you know if 93-95 yep
it was the crease if white even gets an
advantage and I would be that surprised
just because Black has been playing with
that field psychology is that black
multi oh he's getting long time yes he's
like 120 seconds and he knew he was
better right so he's in time-travel he
knew is very still pressing for
advantage and and look at him he looks
upset right he look at sir what does he
realize he's 10 seconds left what's
going on but probably he is muted you
know this time time hood oh but this
night now is beautiful bring that into
the games trade Queens Knight f4 okay
yep black to play well here comes this
Knight to c6 maybe your idea from early
97 96 do it right now would have played
at 6 I would have played at 6 to get
back into at 7 you know protect this e5
you like the pan is linked for us that's
3 3 seconds
rooty 7 just play 57 just go for it ok
oh there's no catch a no no no I think
that was not good that does not look
good yeah now the other group comes to
h8 yep how do you answer well checkmate
I think it just lost 10 ok - and he's
now he's showing his blood skills
yeah ok he found a weapon Wow that was a
pretty epic turnaround there he did he
did a head Bob you know he's feeling it
now
oh he blundered the night back but he
still went ok boy yeah don't keep doing
look f on me no golden key to stop
asking for so much but it's me he's
gonna do it now there it is there it is
it's actually good technique you know
just to make some moves and gain some
time you know not a bad idea actually
yeah she should probably resign because
it gives them more time to come back
right I mean you're talking about the
larger mass strategy with an hour
laughter you know a little bit over an
hour left in this
honestly that was a very much 50/50 game
where we liked Tanya's position of the
opening we liked how levy started
dealing with this position with the you
know after Bishop III would particularly
that was a questionable move and then
let me really took advantage of it he
seized the initiative and then Tanya
fought back and unfortunately for her
this h3 palm was such a weakness that
maybe was able to take forward today I
would say that in majority of the game
Lemmy was in charge
yeah I mean once the opening part was
over he was the clear favorite because
he was out playing white right yep
c5 I'm not seeing this move I think
usually the good b5 right yes with that
you can like don't go ahead no yeah now
you go you go so now we just transposed
to some names Oh Queen Knight f3 right
now I wouldn't not be fived
and then you're into this line which has
been played so many times by all players
at your rating level these positions you
just take on d5 Knight takes d5 with
Bishop d2 right I already put Queen c2
well there's like different moves here
right but like Bishop d2 seems totally
reasonable stop it yeah I think we'd be
trees the main line right and then there
is a move 26 yeah that's what that's the
main line theory but we're not getting
main line theory yeah the time he's
taking I don't think he's you know like
an expert in this line probably see if I
threw him off and yeah Tanya please c5
lines often in the nihms oh so I coach
the other study well I coach the u.s.
women's team and we've played India
before so I've had to prepare my players
for Tonya and she plays these c5 moves
very frequently in this opening so it
shouldn't come as a complete surprise
though it's not a main weapon of other
players so when you study the top games
you'll see it's regular Castle kingside
we have the opportunity to take them c4
for blackfish monji to becomes a monster
doing this is a favorite famous game of
Casper Oh like you take on c4 and then
you an ID b5 right yeah
just going after all of these weak
squares not to mention the bishop on g2
is so powerful it's much easier to play
as white in this portion for blitz I
think it's a good choice by white yep
this is what we need there's also Chloe
need four lines by the way so like
they're only there 92 b5 but too often
times you play some kind of Queen eight
four because your knight on d4 can be
taken but the pitch one before is
hanging as well and sometimes you know
you have to play like move like 96 of
the Queen a foot if I remember correctly
and it's not you don't know then it's
not so simple to do that yeah you don't
like putting in Item eight six nobody
wants to do that so tiny does take on c4
but both players spent nearly a minute
each on their last move so clearly
they're out of their opening element of
their the repertoire is thrown out the
window
here's Queen a4 by levy you know your
boy did I you know I'm just threw out a
move he played it Queen a5 is an option
for black but many these end games as
you were hinting at before are very on
tough for black to play but even though
you're up upon sure by the way during
the show I have some chest buns
do you've chat I want yeah I saw some
chest buns whenever you want it I'm a
little scared that us mas yeah I'm just
like you know it's a lockdown you know
you have not much to do so why not so
have you been writing these puns
yourself by coming up with them yeah I
mean I because of some comedian friends
of mine you know I got this habit of
making puns so now I'm completely
digging it you have been a material
you're the commissary hero
I didn't know I needed that this was
happening not only do you have puns in
store for me that you've actually put
you know at for you you're letting me
know they're coming I appreciate it and
but you know you're like making
decisions too quickly it could also be
the to be that the puns are horrible you
know who knows well they probably know
no they probably will be horrible I'm
anticipating that but I appreciate you
letting me know in advance because Danny
who outcompeted with all time
he just says pawn after ponder is
terrible
but you might have to roll my eyes
because you know he didn't let me know
it's coming at that specific moment in
this portion 97 over should be send
Bishop c6 probably probably Bishop f5
just to allowed 93 with a tempo and to
not say a move that you said so actually
I would played Bishop d7 Bishop c6 them
I like developing why because we should
be setting you up Queen before yeah but
then I can play Knight sees oh you're my
c4 pawn is gonna be lost but I think I'm
okay with that so if Bishop d7 Queen
before I plate you tonight c6 you'll
take on c4 I think that I should be
seven Wow Bishop e6 just attack your
queen I mean Oh Shawn well I mean black
played 9700 g5 okay that's not a move
like that if you ask me or for its six
move recommendations I'm not sure that
was in the top six but maybe it's not a
bad exactly exactly it's not that bad
you know what I would do I would play b7
with an Knight b6 ah no no it is bad
what is this I think Knight b6 + f6 you
grab the bishop yeah the bishops going
down oh yeah look at him I think he sees
it he has to go 95 now yep yes to go 95
oh my gosh but I have to I just turn my
head to the twitch at sailor hats
oh it just it has to be said I don't
know if you know you've been seeing the
chat there by them oh I think I see a
lot of robot faces I have to give a
shout-out to blitz stream and the entire
channel because they know what so
they're ready for the action here Kevin
board he needs to become an
international master so he can play in
this or he's just a wait for the fm9 and
I am or whatever we're fine then he has
to become an infant yeah wait how is it
Oh some 90 d5 necessary move probably we
should be six what do you do it
or you would not publish me six she's
just four she goes for you you don't
need to ask me you didn't ask Tonya and
Tonya answers every time you ask so
Dixon would be one I like white stone oh
I like white to the control over the d8
square having the bishop I'm a big fan
of
Bishop's well what was the Chad thing I
didn't get it you wouldn't get it
you wouldn't get to explain you can't
just like say it and then not tell me
what's happening you know I just yo yo
you'll learn later I'll tell you later I
can't tell you on air but say that it's
what the it's a French expression that
they love saying and it's perfect
because of my last name so it works out
wonderfully
can I just trade Queens and put a rock
on d7 at some point probably not I was
thinking of we need three but then you
have 97 group the 6 and then Queen c5
yep so let's show that quickly route d6
looks like it's gonna be very powerful
but a queen c5 offers the trade of
Queens and then I don't see if I would
be very good for black so now does 97
book because this B should be 7 I'm not
sure if it was what do you think
actually that line before if we just
show them the announce for equivalent
Queen a 397 rip d6 Quincy also hits F -
you're such a devious guy I was hoping
that I could play really crazy move like
Bishop c1 and just like freeze you but
then I thought we should see when you
deserve to get punished how cool is that
people how cool these bishops you want
like if you don't have Queen takes up to
that moves not allowed what move would
you play hey you don't really have a
move so actually I have not seen that so
good at this point to it so because of
the Bashir e7 now the actual player will
cap 7 then again this means if I makes
this threat of twin f2 not the actual
not would do II ate yep so brick f7
whether they are really down on that oh
the 6 no here's 25 what I did well Danny
shot and this is terrible for right now
because not only do you force the Queen
trade because C f2 is hanging but the
[ __ ] 27 is trapped because Queen 595
Bishop g5 runs right in 94 with a 4 run
and you should read for you have g5
exactly thing we should know this is a
bit Indian oh you're such a devil just
rook thx saves everything look at you do
you eat your tangerine load of chess so
I mean I have to spoil a bit
you ate your tactical Wheaties today
so now it would be seven like respond up
yeah completely winning yeah just go
after the C party food is good night if
it was good because it'll get to NZ
please both what the thirteen also look
which time Tania has she's up a minute
in 15 seconds
she's just cruisin sees plenty seats any
five you know that's technique technique
too strong they say except to even that
this meaning they don't get flat and get
off Who am I kidding it's just
yeah but she's conserved her time so
well that she could spend half a minute
here and then decided between a 547 a
routine v f3
that's what she's worried about as three
he goes for it
maybe look if ii was better yeah it
demean it was just free porn yeah now i
think she missed it she missed i can see
from the cam yep but you still winning
rock a seven
okay seven and be five but you know i
don't like to have been rockin games
when I could have won like two pawns
before that Oh who claims have such a
Jewish tendency I really hate it so I
would like King f77 King these six bring
the king this way here comes the king de
to but you know do you rule of the
possibility that this could be a draw I
don't really know very I've rule nothing
out in the I am now GM speeches change
if nothing is also that's the yeah
Brooke f7 ends the game right we're just
yeah yeah give me this I think instead
of King c2 why should I play rook f3
wait what's going on here just get this
egos - yeah it's just lost just closed
okay so that's a good good game for my
name much needed yeah two losses would
be tough to get well once she got the
advantage she played well we saw a sort
of role reversal from the first game
because Levy was out playing Tonya
throughout the first game and Tonya
outplayed levy throughout the second
game so we like the openings how they've
gone for white but we like how black is
respond to the openings would you say
that's a fair assessment
yeah I think open adding who is playing
better in the opening is losing that's
my conclusion so fun now you know why I
never learned openings very well because
this is my smite nice excused
nice excusable but you've never taught
me openings I asked you earlier today I
was ok could you just send a file a
photo of a file in your computer didn't
happen so I blame you
yeah that's my fault Portia let you know
instead you quit your good sense we're
gonna team up together against Danny in
a niche right so you're gonna have to
teach me some openings yeah that's
that's a very important match by there
you should be on the peak of your game
I will there will be my crowning
achievement in chess if we beat them
just just right but I don't really like
what why did what is he for any for this
combination well you don't mind giving
control of the be Foursquare to your
opponent's pieces yes I also like how
quickly levies been playing he spent 4
seconds I would have gone for like 92
rooky 1.e4 you know try to break open
with the center if we go back a few
moves like when white played a 4 here
that's one of those moves where you're
afraid of your opponent's Planum not
even a five to go a four it's the fiend
kiddo structure but a 4 is just this
reactionary move that I think we both
are not too fond of because a fort isn't
the end of the world that black is able
to play it but when you play a 4 and C 4
as Tonya did you're giving control over
some important squares and when you're
facing a Dutch structure you want to be
able to play for efore as white and thus
far it's been black because it's been
able to clog the center of the port and
also one good thing is that black is
playing really fast
yep that's a good sign just play quickly
put opened under pressure and not
White's moves are not so easy right if I
teach and I'm fine 92 in play quickly
just go I take and then go Knight c5 ok
you're a mean person I you know I don't
know what to say and I did this bit move
though because you could still play
something like 23 or eights on c5 it's
not so bad it's not so bad actually I
think it was a good move I appreciate
your moral support here but on a serious
note like
just have to play quickly because at a
certain point playing speedy moves is
more important than finding the absolute
single best move in a position where
there's nothing concrete I think you
know it matters like it differs from
person to person for me sometimes just
being intuitive leading works but I know
many people who like to think for
example ice to watch some games of
Casper oh yeah I used to like to really
think and try to find the best move you
know very principled that way right like
Alexander Grisham yeah and I tried to
imitate that and I feel horribly so
which is on them
yep and I mean and there's no shame in
me trying to imitate Casper oh and
failing no I am gonna shame it for it
just for right
so no Ruby it actually should be twice
as f4 I kind of like whites position
yeah somehow this has turned out really
well because when I see a weak squaring
before I want to put a knight on that
side of the board but black is out of
knights and Knight d4 comes into be five
should be three Malinois you should be
mini chips with them maybe eat four for
white to just break this position open
yeah you foot is a good move your photos
are good move just blast everything open
here I don't really know like what
blacks Queen side is gonna do the fish
one C tied down in the pawn on b7 so it
move like Eve for just opening up the
center more squares for your pieces
whether 4,000 people watching this life
thank you everyone for joining in love
it you're playing the nice guy right now
I don't even know what to do with you
anymore but no seriously thanks to
everybody who's tuning in here for the I
am non-gm speed chess championship it's
going to be a fun event we're only on
our second mat III better explain that
move yeah III soft III soft yeah I just
I would like III go for info like like
was blacking coordination and he's down
in development you know what black
should do now go if I afford himself or
not know then you should be five check
which is right you're actually a very
very good little nuance there is that
throwing in Bishop b5 check and before
night c2 because a black it's key for
the bishop looks a bit suspect still
good for white but throwing in Bishop
defund check first then you
move your night and your bishop is
extremely happy but it was there any
like this prediction thing for this
match like usually chess or tom has a
prediction meter or something right and
stuff
the smarter chess predictions but
they're only endowment chess predictions
for this tournament and you're asking
for too much did it but you know what is
your prediction
what's awards what you if I asked you
it's one to one right now what's your
prediction for the rest this match
it's a good question Oh see you want
other people to answer the question but
now that I put it on you you're not sure
we can you can ask the chat who's the
favorite we can do you know okay I think
for what the routing for but that's
different who's the favorite shoe
they're rooting for right it's a little
bit different okay I'll ask who are they
looking for you know who is their
favorite and then we say that what's the
actual ratio that makes sense right yeah
yeah and well let's talk about this game
here what's making sense to you because
the last couple moves White has been a
little bit slower pace probably three I
don't like it like it's completely fine
I still prefer White's position he would
write still you go youthful yes I would
still play for efore and the reason why
I like White's position is because I do
feel like the side that has easier pawn
mobility as a side I tend to prefer
running if you like a 5-4 black we
talked about this d5 square whereas
white can play f4 or efore ideas like
this but they don't seem to have the
same repercussions and the two bishops
are not a huge advantage here like they
are at some other ones
all right I was just thinking like the
last few news which Tonya split she has
gone back and forth and 9594 really
shows that she she doesn't know what
line she should do and she played edge
for and I don't like that move actually
well some f4 and you know that full
point will be V yep so this game I think
levy is the favorite for sure I agree
and the Bishop on c5 now looks very
strong the night it went from two d4 to
d5 back to d4 back to c2 like that night
needs to find a real home and so far
I've just been dilly dallying in a not a
very good way and the visual at c5 is so
strong because it protects d6 it makes
all of what stacking pieces look like
nothing and before comes in that Bishop
on c5 is let's wreak havoc on the White
King look at the night on c2 you know at
one point it was the hero it was going
to be five and now it's like the worst
piece possible it's never fun when
you're from hero to zero it's just you
know that's a bad night do you think
she's snow issues only quickly maybe six
right if I want any way to like give
some time maybe he's thinking of f4 but
yeah why do you need it b6 is right do
you play king h2 or something for white
just uh you know get out of this
potential pin you know I'd really
dislike White's position it's very hard
to come up with a move I would actually
attempt black to play a fourth right so
you can have some Quincy three and
ninety one is that a good move to go to
be 3x really yeah it's not so bad okay
so just go for okay it's heating up now
it'll be fun so do you take out a 4 and
then play Knight to d3 or do you they
kind of leave it so you take you have to
take on f4 e f4 takes and then you have
Quincy three check don't you yeah Queen
g7 I guessed okay yeah agree with you
then play tonight d3 you trade the
Queen's off and try to take well just
play King it's too you know yeah I'm
sure to take your dark square Bishop d6
is weak the bishop any sevens behind and
I think that at the very least what
should be okay there
so so I'm not sure and I'm not sure if
why it is okay because I feel totally
sure that white is okay okay then he
wants to be it's gonna happen watch it I
have a queen there are there six Queen
f6 black should go Queen f6 not 27
because then you keep the d6 pawn
protector Indian whoa look at six
doesn't 93 just super strong now
FG 95 and then you take FG and the rook
is pinned yep you can't hear because
that would be devastating
I don't like to look at six and okay
brick f6 is not a good move so it was
made actually in the chat they are
rooting for both King a change what
John for now on what what did it help me
out here what has happened in the last
few moves
why do acids tough questions because I'm
not here to make your life easy I'm here
to get to the true understanding of this
game of chess 93 King yet you won't know
f3 after you lose oh my gosh every df2
is bustin it wins the [ __ ] is gone yeah
yeah it's gone oh my god does he not see
it no I found the event okay yeah I
think it's reasonable
no no use a good chance this is the best
chance yet take on g7 take on c5 take on
d6 it's losing we both know it's losing
but this is the best chance she has
relatively speak
and try to take all the pond you can I
think it's good that you'd be saying I
don't think it's good that you she
resigned - you gotta play it out take
compounds and hope that it works how
much three you should match doing hey I
know it's losing you don't have to
convince me I'm just saying when it
comes to blitz sometimes you just have
to play it out John Bartholomew won a
game against David Perez where he was
completely lost because he survived long
enough David got time trouble
and ended up losing on time so I'm just
I'm starting out there you don't seem to
agree with me black is won every single
game thus far that's what I've learned
in this only oh yeah I noticed that
that's a good statistic black is three
you know so let's see if levy with the
white pieces can score a point with
white here very calm set up a trump
offski attack he's probably gonna play
f4 Knight f3 pawn c3 place are you ready
for your first point of the day yes I'm
ready okay so you know it's not mine
someone anonymous sent it okay okay so
what is the favorite strategy of a
person who is OCD David Stremme um tell
me double check
[Laughter]
look at you go you don't mind though I
would have been really happy if it was
mine but yes shout out to the guy who
made this pun that that is adorable
and the chant loves it very they're
happy they're your pawn game is strong
do you think you're a super GM when it
comes to puns well what's your level I'm
trying I try I try I'm like 1919 okay
that's pretty good I will like make more
puns throughout it and then you rape me
in the end you know rate my pun game
okay I'll definitely give it a rating
also I'm being criticized for not taking
a guess I had no idea what you were
gonna say so
you know good on you you know actually
it's it's better if you don't guess it
then you know the punch is more powerful
see there it is I did the right thing
but speaking of the right thing this is
the most solid position you could
possibly get right like both sides have
no true weaknesses over protecting this
'if I've square I think time is doing
the right approach by challenging that
night and center but I always hate this
[ __ ] mom piece up I never feel good
about it I think this Bishop f6 and then
going for Stonewall it looks nice now
but you're it's two bishops right I'm
not um it's you know the good thing is
like in this manner
I'm seeing so the openings we can
normally don't analyze so frankly it's a
new thing so you're learning is what
you're saying yeah I'm learning I'm glad
I could be here to help teach you so the
movie h4 was played because it's a
themed keto pawn structure on the
kingside and one of the Finke at a pawn
shop shoot h4 h5 try to maybe even offer
some sacrifices on the g6 square I don't
think new this vid it but that's a
common theme against the people you feel
like hearing so much okay I'm glad so he
takes a I'm sorry time takes me five and
levy now takes back and F saying this is
how you typically play against this and
Levy is hoping that h5 is in time but I
think I can just ignore it and take on
equip f6 h 5 takes a g e4 right exactly
and just close the audition Bob don't
you have 94 on it so nothing now I see
what you're trying to reshape c4 and you
want me to play Bishop e5 you want me to
play Bishop e5 if I Breton's this
endurance checkmate but I will not hold
in photo I'll play King h8 and after
Queen h5 I'll play h6 and say good luck
check Manning me you're not in time but
there's still an attack you trade rooks
play work f1 and the game continues but
I'm not a maybe actually this those more
dangerous Irish originally thought I do
believe black is better here someone
just wrote in the chat like if more one
come I changed the channel well I'm not
sure we want that person the channel so
maybe they should
so now you take on e5 do you take back I
guess you do probably have to write
already yeah I mean f65 looks pretty
good right then I think back Quincy food
isn't good move endlessly so you're just
trying to get into e6 mm-hmm
what's annoying and also you can if
you're looking at you there's Knight f3
Knight g5 ideas right you could start
with Queen e6 check and it's trade rooks
like there's always this idea to simply
trade rooks and I don't know how black
will take back and then wreck f1 and
it's a very quick initiative it does
make sense it does make sense so but you
start with a different move like yes you
know what's weird I would just take back
on e5 and you know the let's force to
this I like it because you have to think
for more time yeah it goes D yep it's
mean unpleasant to play this portion
with black I must say right I got a 5 is
a very ardent threat young I agree with
you so can black like Queens now Queen
c8 you take on a fate probably
grab the Queen c7 maybe just go for your
ePHI pond but are you gonna Queenie 695
me at some point so sorry what did you
say I missed it I was reading the chant
actually oh I think I put Queen c7 in
this position just to like attack you if
I pond mm-hmm it's a good night so okay
doesn't matter now Quincy it has been
played okay guru K fate exactly what I
see an idea of what you wanted I have
seen that when there is a direct attack
Tanya feels uncomfortable yeah even like
when black had gone H fight for in the
first game she didn't react well yeah I
think I think I think she doesn't like
to face that she's more like a solid
player yeah and there's also something
said about like not playing too much
blitz when you get under attack you your
first instinct is to protect your king
rather than the counter and Oh Queen g3
wasn't expecting that now Queen c7 Queen
c7 maybe Queen e6 even Queen e6 just get
on that square in it Sinai taffy I
wouldn't even take a little gift three
if needed
oh I'm playing d4 to go for this I'm
playing d4 don't get to school
Robert yeah it is cool you're trying to
get e5 and you've tried closed
everything down I agree with it I just
want to have my own time to shine to
once you do that what happened though
it's not gonna happen
hey Queenie six played though yep when
you say side of tea
all right d4 is also a bad move so maybe
I shouldn't be played because it loses
the pot and opens the diagonal for some
good night g5 yeah yeah so you lost that
I do know I love sacrificing other
people's pieces they always do it can
you put a crook up seven instead of rook
takes up three in just like double euro
I saw the comment which is that Lamia
looks like Harry Potter doesn't it they
had been committed by their similarities
yeah there's some 95 9 IG 5 now oh this
is a nasty trick you know Queenie 5 we
exchanged Queens knight of seven
rucastle drew Gibson bishop at six and
rook a f1 King G look at six and b-cell
Bishop is hanging in the end I just
showed everybody that line very quickly
all just a nice line as a bishop hanging
on b7 I told you I hate fighting Diamond
also does edge find the end so why'd you
go Knight g5 so Nigel mine yep sorry I
meant like after okay fun if you remove
the Bishop from b7 to c6 for example
then you have edge 5 yeah
here's crashing through so he put each
one to begin with I you know I think
there are some positions where Tania has
to be very concrete and she's not doing
it like in the last game he played III
instead of E 4 and even now King h8 was
that kind of a move but I like Bishop h6
I might not have like King shape I do
like this wage so I would go Knight g5
Oh would you take on g6 it's a puzzler
if you take on g6 I think there's Bishop
takes III Intermezzo so I think this is
the right move order because I don't
know what black really does here the
threat of age 66 if you take on h5
you're just opening up the Queen's at
age 7 square but at 6 in VN me in the
end
and then you have Bishop g6 King g7
Bishop f5 and it should be lost
good one yep just quick attack
so now Queen Jesus Quincy it what what
d for know oh we have our first check
men in one blunder of the day and I
think I think it's slipping away then
that game was that that was a tough one
wait wait oh you know of all the people
and the least one to get embarrassed
about when missing a meeting one you
know I wasn't if nobody knows I've
missed meeting one twice in my life so
see I was never on this yeah you're the
one who burned up not me I'm sorry I
can't really say I've missed Ragman in
one move
I'm just gonna throw that out there so
that's a Yankee yeah but let me ask you
something now that it's 3 to 1 and let
me savor that's not that big of a leap
right that changes in but I'd smash the
how the games are going you know I feel
the trend is towards he's dominating I
think that's that's what I feel how
about this gating he's down 30 seconds
on the clock and it's only moved 9 okay
doesn't matter a second I'm just I'm
just trying to play devil's advocate
here I agree with you that levy in that
last game was actually quite impressive
by levy there was a miniature nice for
both look good he sustained the momentum
he really was in charge that whole game
and Tonja right now with the white
pieces here she's facing this Dutch the
levy keeps trotting out here and white
position is very solid she's gone for an
aggressive approach
she needs to be a bit careful about her
d4 pawn and that's the whole idea what
black is going for is if you take on you
for F takes you for and then down goes
your d4 pawn once you're not enough
three has to move queen d3 I would say
then you take on 16 v five I think that
is a good choice by levy even I had I
played Dutch against Anya encroach
asleep because you know it keeps a lot
of pressure not many exchanges yep yeah
it's very hard to figure out the exact
path for because when you face the Dutch
your toes it should be good for white
because you touch your golden pawn your
your f7 pawn on the first move and there
should be some weaknesses that Y can
exploit but it's actually very difficult
practice and this is a good example that
their tactical elements here that white
needs to be careful
everyone thinks that whenever I'm
drinking from this it's vodka I don't
know what you're drinking I wasn't
making any judgments regardless but I'm
glad you're quenching your thirst that's
very important so let's see Queen D 3
you guys taking so much time you know I
think you should not go take more than
like minute minute and a half right it's
right usually a bad idea in such time
control no it's a liking for 50 minutes
in classical game equivalent to that 14
15 minutes yeah I mean the line you
point out Queen B 3 1930 Queen to e5
sure black maybe okay but just take on
e5 and continue the game there and
there's no real tremendous risk in white
position just yet so the real risk is
getting a ton trouble and they're not
having adequate amount to deal with the
complications that arise so just play
Queen D just go for it I think this game
is really important for Tanya if she
loses this it would be very hard
psychologically to come back right
being out three games in a match where
your opponent's the favorite and bullet
is yeah not the recipe the doctor
ordered
what else can you play here besides
quindi 3 by the way we should do that's
your answer
she answered it but she said I'd moved
on no she spent two minutes and 10
seconds on that move really oh yes a lot
that's a lot like even if the move is
fine it's bad when you spent 2 minutes
to make it that's how these matches end
up working because the Blitz game mm-hmm
but we should be too I mean actually she
played a good move record this long
thing so that's we should be doing
questions how do you play with black
right right because you protect the
knight on c3 and now Knight takes d4
isn't by 94 Bishop d4 Knight 64 politics
before and some kind of Bishop takes d4
at the end of it and essentially white
regains the pawn and has some momentum
in the position so I agree I think it is
a good move but I just wish she had
played it more quickly for her sake more
than anything you're wishing for a lot
of things probably you know I'm a very
hopeful person how about rookie three
here they just go Knight d5
yeah and I'd be fired no I really rotate
three somehow it's possible though no 94
what do you do okay - yeah I'm just
trying to get active here attack your
nighttime see the ring I wouldn't play
III or something or should be one right
so just kicked a broken and movie and
black is also thinking for like a minute
and a half already so it okay three it
is so minute minute and a half think
they call me the levee whisperer yes I
don't know if you notice these crazy
moves that I've suggested they happen
and levy is doing as I have recommended
which is probably not a good thing so
queen c1 that makes sense just attacking
the roof
there's some kind of Knight takes d4 now
tonight 62 played Queen d2 what 92 oh
okay yeah that's a bad move but just
Queen d2 looked monomial yeah this
doesn't look normal but the broken a3 is
under attack
so yeah and rooks into is not Sofia
Quincey 394 okay so it goes back
III if I be 593
maybe five you play see I don't like d5
and like defy now you have this Kings
Indian kind of should go f4 just close
this for once and all your comes e4
before and now it's getting really
complicated but ninety five wand well I
wanted my knight see forward I'm worried
about the default on just being lost
right 94-year played DC 5 DC 595 and I
wasn't sure that I'm getting any plumber
ok DC I wouldn't even go to p1 well you
are happy to sacrifice other people's
pieces you're learning from me this is
great I'm happy but yeah I knew that
eventually she would take on d6 which is
not bad move but the bet the bad part
about it is you've opened up some lines
for blacks pieces we need a pawn on c5
and on c7 it was just much more active
for white now there's clarity in the
position and that should help relax
chances moving any more d1 you know what
she's playing soft eared I think CD and
then double D one I feel it's soft I
mean if she wanted to do this she should
have gone directly because after Knight
defiled there was an idea for tactic
yeah so black couldn't take on d5 so CD
was a mistake or Sadie
it just is too accommodating for sure
okay now Knight B 394 stop this diagonal
no that doesn't work 93 Brooks CA 94612
files go for your sacrifice look at you
you're just sacrificing all the pieces I
love it I'm a big fan of your
sacrificial mindset but it wasn't gonna
happen
so nightly to played trying to meet rook
c8 with Queen to a3 so if I'm welcome
you know they trying to get rook F to
see it like that one just drop the Queen
if I could never serve a food right so d
Bishop a4 oh gosh
Knight bTW you go 493 and then Queen d2
so you're sort of weaseling your way out
of it and night on e 2 is about to land
on e6 right Knight okay I mean I'm
waiting for night at 496 that's like the
dream night at foot is a good find
I didn't see you United for Queen a3
we're just starting to turn around it
feels like
good here goes you can't easily take on
d5 at any moment cuz Queen a2 will pin
that night to the coalmine d5 so night
at 4 through my Brooksie seem to be
that's nice and then you kind of lose my
to do yeah but then I have a nice night
b3 I don't know this is like weird
everything's getting weird that's the
word but there's no time here for Tata
you go Queenie you know after night be
to you what we need so I think we should
be three that's pretty cool no yeah
you're you can't save it
here comes we but actually Brooks III is
a queen bee - OH
deeply Queen g7 yes example you know no
it doesn't work it doesn't work
King Drasil 96 king of six this is more
your news - no Luke see - oh no when it
was bad
yeah it's disables oh just one hope that
you get 96 6 g7 and Queen see then check
again so no black Huntsman black beans
over to Queen on the C file after 96 96
Quincy 8 no I'm aware but if you don't
put a queen on C file then that's when
blunders happen yeah but you know it
wouldn't be six or something Knight d7
to d5 doesn't matter
no but then why 96 oh then 96 sorry
okay so Queen d7 I'm at least like she
drew in the CA is the move office
I mean Queenie seven also looks very
good now you talk about it
just don't play Queen b6 or queen what
97 or know what y'all think right into
it we're just expressing this this was
the only trick in the in that position
oh no that's how you turn a win into I
think just a bad position now because
even if you win the d5 pawn I'm worried
about blacks King so objectively I think
blacks should be okay still but it's a
very risky looking position and levees
facing oh I totally missed that
whoa wait what what is happening is you
f3 that's such a turnaround no oh wow I
think I would appear to be to just stop
this d2 is 51 just put that Bishop there
d2 look a fun you have a look at fun
you're such a little trickster work
everyone
don't play rookie today 95 95 yeah me
too oh no this is too passive she lost
oh no did it no it beans it really hurts
because she tricked him she made her way
out of it and then unfortunately if we
bring up the announcement next things he
under way we'll bring back the analysis
for it we'll just talk about this moment
here where the D pawn was still
threatening she'd won in exchange after
Knight takes rook takes e8 Bishop f3
rook c8 and you were saying that you
were just like rook to d2 and stop the
pawn once and for all I agree with that
I think that is a good strategy but
after even what she did with Bishop d1
Pondy to work out for one night 65 if
she plays rook to be to here she wins
the pawn on d2 like black cannot protect
that pond and so it's just a winning
position for white regardless up in
exchange yeah that was really painful to
watch yeah that uh likes I mean yeah
what can I say I'm gonna go to the live
game because I can't look at that
position anymore it's too painful
but unfortunately Tonya who she had a
bad start to that game and she was being
outplayed the entire way she found out
one tactical resource and Levy was like
oh this is going south very quickly she
had the chance to you know cut the
deficit to three to two and instead she
blundered that one away and Levy is very
fortunate to have a 4-1 lead I think we
need one more fun one more come on I'm
ready
what's the pun okay again it's not mine
it's a fair
made by the comedian you know in that
show but I'm sure you have not heard it
so just for you
okay so why is the LightSquared bishop
so fast
because it moves the speed of light no
because it's on f1 oh my gosh that is I
thought I had a good answer I thought I
had a little you know a punny response
to your phone but that is that's a good
one that's it that's why he's like a
million and then not and I like the chat
saying thanks for the pun warning vidit
I turn the volume I think it's a yeah
you you know you just went full michael
schumacher on me and I don't know if I
appreciate it but you know your your
pawns are good they're gold I'm happy to
be the person that you bounce them off
of and all right so be 597 I think the
blacks position is generally speaking
fine here I tend to like having the
bishop pair and Bishop b2 trying to
break open the long diagonal it's
something to look forward to but it's
not very easy to accomplish you know
what there's a line it is a game I think
of Hari Krishna when it was we should be
to long tassel with white and just blast
open on the Kings side it's a very good
game I don't know why I mentioned that
but just I approve your self-reflection
you're like I don't really know why I'm
talking about this but I'm gonna keep
talking about it anyway and well when
you look at this position video you see
that white has liberation and freedom of
expression that's true that I am happy
that you feel free to talk about
whatever you would like in front of me
this is a true friendship here but what
I was gonna ask you is in these
positions when you look at it right
White has the bishop pair black as a
head of development what kind of plans
should we be looking at so that the
viewers and can that take something away
from this like what either side but
particularly with black cuz I don't
really know one of the things we're just
thinking off is to play 96 game and go
like 94 95 try to play on the Kings side
you know white is sooner or later going
to play d4 then you play a four and try
to get like 96 nine is for you
some things in type of attack that's
what I'm sure and I think you d threose
place that efore can come and the bishop
will land on the kingside it starts for
Bishop but we might cry like d3 because
94 was on I'm straight
yeah and each six again that's one of
those moves you're talking about yeah
again it's very slow it's not in the
spirit of the position that's what I
think
I think it's counterproductive because
if white plays h3g 4 and then g5
sometimes white doesn't have to Castle
because the King is very safe in the
center and now white can actually go
back to Bishop b2 ideas with h3 and g4
and open up the King side so h6 is a
hook that helps White's potential attack
so so a four plate can Bishop h7 she's
trying to get the bishop out of the way
so Eve for ideas don't come with a tempo
but black needs to break something open
and that sounds counterintuitive when
you're porting to the bishop pair
bishops love open space but the nights
are so cramped on f6 and East 7 it sound
like the rooks in the queen are doing
anything for black and you castles King
side here so I'm looking at some moment
for efore as a strike for blood
but give me some space please video
you're suffocating me you want to play
you for with black I just want I just
want something to do but I don't doesn't
get open like you know the diagonal from
b2 to g7 I'm not sure I know what it
does and I'm happy to deal with
repercussions because I don't see what
else goes on here when what do at least
get some play something to look forward
thank you you you get me because
psychologically it's very difficult when
you know you're worse and also have no
ideas but maybe times fine job I see six
I guess and I don't know what c6
accomplished it oh okay that's I don't
like that move c5 is hot it below
why isn't here comes to mind would you
please see five just maybe we should be
too yeah that move your position that
move came very unexpectedly and I'm not
a fan of it now you know there's a
chance that black might even get better
yes putting it down but Queen a3 Queen
the Queen b3 is also possible now do you
think you would take on c5 I was just
highlighting that pawn I would certainly
consider this is nasty
typing night a food that's tricky I
name's Ricky I'm gonna show that like if
you ate three night or for between say
c6 Knight 62 check Intermezzo and then I
take the Queen backing them up piece so
Tonya going for a nice tactical approach
my JD said Queen e6 me too because it's
not just like going for a cheapo tactic
it protects 'if I've so the threat is
actually D 65 as well just win a pawn so
it's a multi-purpose move that I simply
like see that's why I wonder to Queen HD
yes cuz Queen if I lose such a bad move
yeah because when you were position when
you're squeezing your opponent you have
the bishop pair there's no reason to let
those nights out I was just talking
about how the Knights had no space they
were very much cramped and while c5
allows immediately black to jump into
this position and have full life and
looked at time advantage by the way up a
minute oh no now queen a3 and then we
have like 5500 people who have joined us
that's pretty good well I appreciate
every single one of them except if Dani
wrenches watches he
then I we could lose that viewer but my
name all day yeah night before going to
see two with a fork yeah it is
yeah in time shoes yes
she's like much more quickly this game
too and there's there's an ambulance I'm
not thinking here that I've moved I'm in
a new apartment from where I have
counted for the last bunch of years your
most when I move where did I move to
I'll tell you that later because I don't
want the public knowing my so many money
find me to see yet but I will tell you
later you know what we're not in front
of all these viewers I don't want
everybody knowing where I look but I'm
in their cities the city I've been
sitting oh I'm in New York City stuff so
it's a night before he's down to forty
seconds Oh
cd1 wait night - can I see - you have to
be three square in the end oh no what
- Queen e2 or no Queen sit down 91 night
be hungry three fish away three and then
I distract that's actually really sneaky
that's tricky
ladies tricky okay
tricky live so Brooke FCA 88 90 85 maybe
Oh but actually Brooke Upstate 95 95 as
possible because your night yeah you
should be one you should be one right
now I would play night before
Indy and then 95 or you're you are
directly 95 I don't so good just
creating some weaknesses here I have no
clue if it's good but it looks good to
me so that's all that's all the
confirmation you need all it matters to
be yes so 95 should be good you most my
evil to the stream and that's why I've
joined it right development I mean if we
just go back in the history of you
commentating I was the one who robbed
you in initially so I brought you into
this thing just so I could booster you
know England all self-esteem you gotta
keep me well I'm hearing
subsea isn't love because there's no
reason it should be but if it is loving
just I'll be that friend that you need
you know lean on me when you're not
strong I will be your friend
during such oh no yd4 I don't know
you're asking the tough questions
you're a lot a fool we could have played
Bishop b2 attacking d5 also covering
group c3 yep the Bishop b2 was an option
D for what whoa what
my mind is blown I would never have
thought of that but she's trying to go
Brooke c3 or something or EDI elephant
leave right that's the point
Bishop d3 why was that necessary Queen
d2 now is why is life seconds over Queen
B - and whoops e3 e4 yeah there was this
tactic yeah but where's just what is
five seconds so I don't really blame
anything that goes wrong at this point
but black but you know I agree with that
for sure so what is black on doing this
from the Brooklyn 83 is really weirdly
placed you just bring it back to c3 at
some point if I brooksy85 g4 of the rook
c8 - watch out for that yeah I think now
I would just take white I think it's
probably plus two in this position was -
yes then I'll just throw it out the
United States an incorrect a certain
weight 15s i someone can verify it I
don't know 15 seconds in B - all right a
queen number three Bishop f3 loses well
well Queen d6 I was suggesting instead
of oh no oh no what mook even play to
keep this one gun do anything it's too
late wait two seconds it's a bullet game
yet oh yeah it's time the time factor
pure bullet no this isn't going well for
Tonya like in all these moments here
where she's out playing her opponent
that's a possibility I just I think she
missed Quinn DT I don't think she saw
that it's hanging you know when DT I
don't think she planned to take Group C
to indicate C right you play Brooks III
first then put your Bishop on d3 like
there was no need to play this fancy I
think she's just blender it's like a
dream I mean will bring up the analysis
board just to highly demo more time and
it's not to call these players I don't
need just it just goes to show that
sometimes when you're not on your apps
of
for me making unnecessary decisions and
in that last game to play after d4
Bishop d3 was completely unnecessary
you're giving away your bishop
for no real reason starting with rook c3
is perfectly fine black is up in
exchange for just one pawn so it's a
rook for a dark square bishop in a pond
and all of these moves look good but
Bishop d3 was just so unnecessary and
the game went south murder after that so
an unfortunate decision by Tanya she's
so much time before playing that much
time is left by the way for their first
Section eight and a half minutes so 8
mavs Millett slowly the last game right
it's the last game before it depends how
long you scheme goes but they have been
playing very very long games that all of
these games feel like they've down to
the waning seconds and she needs this
game that's for sure she's spending a
lot of time in the opening but she has
this sort of ready position that should
be relatively straightforward in terms
of ideas but the problem when you
probably is for white is you're still
looking for some kind of advantage and
d3 I think is a good choice maybe
triangle Bishop a three but Knight a six
to be fourth is always impossible to
meet this idea
and Queenie six as well just protect the
e5 and stopping Bishop a3
so very what's your experience like in
these depositions
I like black you know I like Center I'm
old-school person I like center and I
don't like this hyper modern stuff where
you play around the center and you guy
who is the center and then a menu you
know I'm that kind of okay so you're
you're the type of guy who wants all
your pawns in the center
you just want all the good things unless
I mean you know I I don't blame you it's
a little bit selfish but I don't blame
you and here's 96 so the night you
should be too before yes just close it
down on the diagonal and then you can
play Knight to e4 pawn c5 you can choose
how to continue on the Queen side
beautiful good yeah there it is now I
would like to play III you know somehow
we'll get that break in you know but you
can't do that with your d3 pawn I just
yeah I think one of the things Tonya
should do is she's like when she gets
now she'll play some move which will not
be how to put it very concrete you know
it might just be like a normal move rook
e1 or h3 a e3 something like this I
think Luke you are not a tree Fu do you
think there is a false sense of security
when you play five minutes because a
three yeah which is a move that you and
I would play pretty much instantly but
my question is when you play five minute
do you feel a false sense of security
because typically when you play blitz is
three minute today oh I have so much
time to think so I might as well spend a
minute on a move here in there I think
what happens is like you compare your
time with your opponent yeah if you're
too low on time then you kind of start
to play fast but as long as you both at
the same time you both are in the same
rhythm that's what you care about
I don't think it's the right approach
but it's one of the things which happens
yep that's I think fair assessment and
c5i levy he's playing good moves quickly
at this point because you're stopping
this b4 push and the problem in these
type of structures for white is the
knight on D - it's and nine of three
stepping on each other's toes the bishop
on g2 should be your best piece but you
can't really open up that diagonal is
where's the knight on f3
nowhere that I see but Queen see to it
just do notice notice like I just notice
right now that the first move was d3
was it the mas slip prom she wanted to
play d4 Antipodes feet transfer I just
forgot about that I didn't even notice
that you're good to call that out it's a
d3 in the first term she's a d4 player
not a d3 player probably a mouse slip
but we're in a position now where for
white you you you have to do something
otherwise yours getting squeezed so some
kind of rook e1 e3 and she buddy yeah
this could be just play fast like play
intuitively now you know right but it's
very hard to do that when you're losing
games until you come to a stage where
you're like I don't care what happens I
just play
that's what yesterday of confidence
sorry no that's what David Pruett said
yesterday he was saying that he was
losing like the first four games he lost
all four so then he just I didn't have
confidence in myself to move quickly she
was like I think if she's able to score
a victory in one of these games which
the three-minute time controls she will
be more confident and ready to play I
see that she's playing faster so that's
good see thanks da CD CD and then c5 I
would go with white yeah some space
otherwise even just get squeezed that's
a very very important including for
white because I've seen before you make
some mother move the knight comes to c5
well that guy's all the space in the
world but if you can play see if I first
is white Charlie Brooker see one night
see for some moment get your knight
involved all to this be food but I'm not
sure they know if it's working now I
don't think before man because too much
see there it is so even if she played d3
by accent she's a good feel for this
position yeah yeah you're right you're
absolutely right so now we should be 694
right yep 27 makes sense property one I
guess pretty sure this good move on this
way
but you know can you play Knight c4
still 95 96 but it's too much what do
you what the thing is not c4 I might
take with the Queen on c5 which is what
I'm worried about
I would still go like before right but I
think what she's aiming for is just rook
FTE one because there is
B tension on this Eve I'd walk but and
we should be six now yeah oh yeah you're
totally fine Bishop e6 rook F e1 and
there are some problems down in file
yeah there is some 94-95 ideas exactly
I'm trying to give my another night into
the action to go after you Father
at least not now why does something to
leave like there's a clear-cut plan and
my coach used to say that if you know
you're next to three moves your position
is probably fine
yeah one rule of what if one of your
next three moves is to resign that is
the exception to the rule okay well I
just wanted to let everybody know that
there are principles and then there are
laws you know and there are principles
and principles which are made by me so
that's that's fair so I was checking but
Brooke Kathy wants she's fine this
quickly and she's now actually not I
almost made it on the clock I like that
you just play fuss just blip us and if
you're levy here you're like wait is
night see for coming door really a few
worried about that it's the c5 pawn two
week plays Brooksie nice easy ward just
throw night C for it no but 95 96 now be
threatening what's happening
well the b3 pawn is hanging in those
lines were 94 95 96 like even nineteen
Spieth Orion you know there's a very
cool line so night c4 95 95 95 95 Bishop
Knight b3 I got Quincy eight yeah look
c8 rook c8 Bishop c8 we should be defied
checked yep if we should be 6096 you're
such a demon yeah I'm I don't even think
this working King f8 like Jesus
yeah after it fishery 696 is age 66
Cokie 6 and then Queen c5 okay I've be
should be tree yeah the game continues
but black is uh still up some material
right that's all such a cool and I'm
sorry to ruin it freely you know you
make I think I have good ideas and then
you just find better idea so for once
and here it comes now g6 is weak there's
a huge difference here she played a
little spooky
she changed because the pawn on h7 no
longer protects g6 that was so tricky I
like
I love that that was devious I'm here
for this game is so important for her to
stay in the Mensch yep she needs this
game and actually this is going to be
the last game of this well let's take
finished like 20 seconds this will be
the last game of the 5 minute portion
Queen d2 played getting out of the c5 I
would just take on c4 you know I would
not get at this point if I'm giving up
the be sure I would just take over that
night so annoying yeah this night is a
real pesky piece and Bishop takes c4 how
would you take back the beep on or the
rook I don't think the beep on I think
but I don't know I'm just trying to get
some sort of advantageous situation what
absolutely to be pawn I don't know what
to take with you've got scared announced
it like you know am I getting judged for
that I felt judged so I had to be like
hey maybe you know it's just we're
looking at but this is obviously logical
because you're putting pregnancy father
Knight only six in particular is a bad
piece I think windy too was a mistake
maybe after this game we can all have a
look at that position 94 oh yeah head
before d6 is really bad move 94 go for
it or not a boy no 94 Knight 64 yeah I
don't see it then Knight xb3
oh no guess 8 and I just take back and I
faint I take your rook and c1 call me
I'm sure he likes to put this edge but
95 know I love age 5 I just like I know
it's awesome it's distraction like even
if it's not good it's so nice I was
winning for way come on maybe if I was
winning for it okay but we're not trying
to find all the winning moves though
this is still winning look at this oh
look at the time black is really long
time that exactly that's why I loved H
Friday thank you Knight g5 take on c6
this is if there is no Bishop d3 white
will win I call it if there's no way
Bishop d3 like in the last game
no not like I said what Bishop e3 Bishop
e3 go for the big group finish it knew
when the exchange books fall
oh sure III didn't go away but this
looks also really good just take on that
for what no don't think that one okay
this still is good that's how good that
her position is that chicken - six - six
yeah that looks pretty good just been
read this mission okay I don't
understand what's happening why is she
playing first
because she's trying to flag him and she
did see that did it stop questioning
Tanya that is the end of the five minute
segment I need a breather after these
wild games nope this game is not going
to be a thing they're born in the game
we're gonna take a brief break when we
return you'll have the three-minute
portion of this matchup between levy
Rosman and Tanya's octave stay tuned
it's been a fun one and it will continue
to be a great time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we welcome you back you just want to
give some information about some
upcoming events held on chest comm there
is the European online chess champion
coming our way
may 16th there'll be a lot of fun look
for details how to sign up how to get
involved and play some great chess and
of course we have the premium arenas on
chess calm lots of money at stake for
the members to take part in to our blitz
marathons 300 blitz and it should be
great fun you get to play the likes of
some of the strongest players in the
planet including a card Nakamura and all
those guys so they usually play so
should be fun stream away have a great
time and of course there are the title
Tuesday events that have been on chest
comm every single Tuesday of that we'll
see you know typical cast of characters
including five-minute Caruana Mexican
villa Grove Hikaru Nakamura and well bid
it I want to ask you today's daily
question because we haven't asked yet in
general but the question of the day is
which of the I am now GM participants
will eventually earn the title of Grand
Master my heart says Daniel inch but
what is your brain say my brilliance is
Alena crush lean square okay she has to
GM noms right already I think yep she is
true GM normal I think she's around
twenty four eighty twenty four ninety so
she's right about that threshold and I
think that's a pretty safe just for the
record in my heart dudes with Danny so
that kind of hurts because if your
hearts with Danny and not with me that
makes you a very smart man
if I had to answer that question I think
that Elena's great choice and kursi yet
because she's 16 years old she's a
master she I didn't vote oh yes she
Bijou and June with the black piece of
the Karen's Cup and she's proven her to
be a mighty competitor at just 16 years
old so I think both of them are great
choices and well games are underway so
we have Tonya with the black
and be 46 I like that she's trying to
change her openings and she's playing
quickly so that's the first sign of
improvement I just go here just either
take on a Ford don't but don't spend
your 12 seconds thinking about whether
to do that or not oh yeah whether it
just for the record if we heat 6000
viewers yeah I tell chespin again but
okay then I did then I'll zip it you
know what part of the problem with you
say at 6,000 the people in the chat
already watching so they can't add to it
so the people who need to hear that are
not hearing what you're offering look I
don't know what to do maybe the people
here will relay that message to their
friends or oh that is too much demand
then man so we have Bishop g3 here do
not take on g3 and that's what white
plays this move for is that you take on
g3 after h6 g3 the Rockettes the open
each felt I couldn't do what is the
worst move that white can play let's a
black news night of 6 what is the worst
move that I can play become what you say
b3 oh ok well you're I was kind of like
Bishop c4 or something you know
something oh but the point is B 3 LS
Queen a pod check when the bishop is
under attack the king is in check and
typically you have Knight c3 to defend
the bishop but when you play b3 you lose
defense that square so nice job did it
teaching everybody a little tactical
trick there thank you I learned from you
ninety-seven is a [ __ ] to me - yeah
well name Bishop so busy with the b5 and
then went on a yo-yo string right back
to e2 and the 97 we can go to f5 at some
moment so it's not like it's on a bad
square here I think that why would you
play Bishop e2 and then c3 well I'm just
by seed right away yeah I don't get it
you know what I'll try to predict the
Moose Iran just for fun like what they
will do and I see how how right I can
get you know guess to move during
protests league and all that you would
be dead last if you play guess the move
right now
we should be certain I do okay night at
5:00 No
so night of five will be played at some
point otherwise what's this night doing
on e7 but there are many Lionel and
there is a really nice trick there's a
very nice trick I think you win a pawn
show me if black allows it like Bishop
d6 26 DC if bc that was 94 oh you sneaky
sneaky man
the queen is under attack the pawn can't
take on e4 c5 goes down in flames look
at you look at us just to still live in
Paul Rudd wait what about nettings no 94
now yes we're on the same page let's go
we fight tactics night you know I think
levy just did an eye roll after like
night before here's like what he was
like what is happening to me that's a
free pawn I will play Knight f6 check in
just do it quickly just go sacrifice the
knight here to open up the black King a
little bit more because you're losing a
pawn regardless so you might as well
just get rid of this knight Knight of 6
right you won't get blame
yeah but then take C D you know d8 then
the note C and yeah I know it's bad the
position yeah I'm with him
but sometimes you just gotta do what you
gotta do you know every time you know I
say something then you're like look you
bleep with it
look I know I know just stop talking
look look look do you feel chastise do
you feel like I'm acting like a parent
would you know the reaction chickens
meal yeah I mean makes me check on sorry
I I do what I can to make you laugh
because when you laugh the people win
that that feels like a totally you know
obvious thing when did it is happy the
people are happy and I feel like a chat
will agree with that so here's what
we're aiming for so what is she thinking
about
she's not gonna take wait why don't you
take the 9400 there's some tricks here
we're like night of five coming where
you win the Peace of Queen 64 but know
this Queen eight Forge net I don't know
B five yeah with what why didn't she
what was room a bit of take c4 wasn't
that just a queen an extra pawn I'm
trying to see if I'm missing something
no you're not so let's stop no I don't
want you to hurt your brain you weren't
missing anything visual take c4 was the
move okay this is like you know you're
getting so many opportunities and then
you're letting it go the only time you
should let it go as and watching frozen
but right now this is all where black is
still better right you can take on e4 oh
you can't go rook t2 because you're
recognized hanging so nope
ignore that idea
Queenie five is that do something wish
ff3 and then Bishop c6 Vince you do have
Quincy to always yeah I'm trying I'm
grasping at straws what I'm trying
look at you yeah look look look how
queasy six here is tray Queens oh quit
six probably good day six you you know
again it's one of those moles which is
not decisive enough it's like my typical
a six kind of moves which I really don't
like she's going to play Knight see now
she's not about 96 but she was going to
play Knight seasick okay
No
okay you're not missing anything I
needed your reassurance there because I
wasn't expecting Bishop takes e4 yeah to
give the bishop doesn't make any sense
to me
okay they're low on time so anything can
happen right I don't have popcorn but I
do have grapes sleep now little show
anything can happen everything will
happen before so c4
Brooksie my dear I'll be three I
predicted Knight a5 yes you know it can
still happen on the next move no no
bites you a knight Knight Ford's that
night back to e7 was better that's for
sure
oh I like that McQueen before in before
positioning that's a great movie you
take them before I take with the a pine
cement your wheels on it I think I think
black will win this who 95 is atactic
time time is low oh nice okay now II
what will be to g7 Brooke c7 never cafe
no thank you for Queen GI ticket queen
g4 go for it okay we got into one no
Keith what h58 oh not anymore
you're on three points this is so much
fun yeah okay yeah from da drink we take
we invite 53 no no y-you okay one I
don't know aro B 3 it would be 3 yeah
okay let's not analyze 37 no no I think
times has been worse in the time
scrambles
it just that's what's coming down easy
that was crazy that game could have gone
either way
but in the time scrambles levy has
proven to be the better bullet player
yeah so yeah I mean the position I don't
even remember what it was how did we get
here like black was wheeling upon in the
opening and then we shall be four and
then everything happened Queen b3 now
yeah let's meet meet like Queen b3 going
after f7 okay or not yeah you don't know
what you're talking about that's what
I'm learning every time you suggest a
move it doesn't happen yeah clearly I
have no clue just kidding my friend
okay so whites position is great you
have this pawn on d5 Bishop see you're
more developed you're more space but in
the long term black isn't ready knight
c6 Bishop d6 Knight f6 if you're not
that reminds me of the first game right
something exactly what exactly I I like
black solution simple to play Bishop d6
at finite f6 but I feel like if you were
playing classical game you would much
prefer White's position but because it
splits you prefer black um I think did
you see levy did just head dance yeah he
so he's still doing him he's getting
involved he's feeling it now
should we call levy or Kevin cuz you
know I I know there's some Kevin board
II fans out there who think that levy
kinda looks like bloodstream at the
moment
so do what you don't know Kevin bordey
Blitzer yeah I know I know I know I
think people were saying with his facial
hair levy has a little bit of blitzing
going on
okay okay you clearly don't agree I'm
gonna change the subject so I don't
embarrass myself further so when we're
gonna look at this position you like
black here I was saying that White's
strong control over the center is
advantageous and you just like it easy
to play I used to play the two night
strangle when I was young I have very
fond memories so I like this night six
night at six business got it so you're a
fan of the Knights on the kingside yeah
okay so should white somehow bring this
night over f3 is that what you're saying
I'm c3 every note with why you just
don't do anything you just avoid like
you play Bishop b2 we should be three
yep and Group C one try to play 94 you
have to play on the Queen side right hey
you got your pan now over 6k on so oh
okay okay I did just tell this point in
my phone's stream but I go for it again
right okay okay so wait what was it
that's a great pilot okay okay why did
Amazon hire petrol sure
I'm stuffed go because he was good at
exchanges oh my gosh oh my god that
one's bad I'm sorry now what is that
nope no I'm not here for that one
I loved your other puns that one is a no
[Music]
please everybody move in please
you go with you come up with a pun hey
the viewership just dropped after
hearing that and I hope you're aware of
that so yeah that has me a bit tongue
twisting here I don't feel good about
what's happened mister takes age six is
probably what tania's hope oh yeah I
kind of followed that with the fun thing
no you know ninety to g5 so you're
getting all sorts of aggressive actually
I mean that makes sense the Kings on H a
you're ready to open the G file for your
rook to swing gee look at the time
difference by the way huge yes huge time
difference should be wide Riley it shows
the lack of confidence you know I think
why 905 there it is sorry go ahead again
and I think the viewers should prove me
wrong by again going to 6k and
- every time you BMI you go to 6 K we
got a new pond is that what's happening
no Justin this is just for my ego so
that the viewers didn't leave after the
pun okay I think they did though so it's
already over but I think this was the
wrong move order she took on f4 before
playing Knight of five she could have
played mattify first just to scroll
thanks daddy
all the night before is a good move go
Knight f3 back now take the bishop on e5
oh my go to line position since you're
here yeah 94 is good go night after I
agree but I think she could have done my
first rookie one though because there's
bishops III write in 25 seconds Bishop
e2 she's just trying to stop f3 at all
costs that's clear should be - she was
worried about some kind of a take on d4
and f-35 I like it I like g5 good fight
go getting too aggressive with it
Knight if I haven't you seeing my games
I play like that
now you don't you're very proud of the
compliment yeah don't don't don't lie to
me like I've seen them double your games
in fact you might will commentated on so
many of your games at this point my
dream Knight g4 Quidditch 5 is gonna be
me oh yeah I never have 394 ft no will
ok now what to do whoa 90 isn't
something has been Bishop take Z to just
you've know everything
I would I would play f3 and completely
blunder Queen at 6
yeah don't do that I was looking at that
source you know waiting for somebody to
say it and that's a point maybe maybe we
should eat - and then again go Knight g4
yeah e4 is also hanging right so you
could just steal a pawn is so much time
if so much time 94 take take the pond
it's not dangerous
take your steal it take it Peters would
say take it and go they take it and
think later is what you're advocating
for I think he's in five rook g5 no you
took it
I mean d3 yeah it's a good move right
just me takes me to keep stealing pawn
on a greedy levy yep it's because it's
practical its spectacle is feedback -
Oh fr you can still do it you can still
take one B - no do seven no he's not
gonna I think anything can happen now
oh for sure Oh indeed and what we should
be for why the because so good on f3 it
was the ng - that was not a good
decision
yeah you're right actually Tonya in time
pressure some dances playing some moves
which is completely suspending away her
advantageous rate yes
wait Queen d7 I would try out a Queen d7
shock of Queenie six or something this
is who gets five last year it's gone
you're gonna find check mean - I like it
yeah
all my openings oh that's not good
so did it I was gonna bring him a bad
memory of yours since you know acting
like I didn't know your chess games but
I helped I kept it to myself isn't that
good well you can go ahead with it you
know no talk button in the stream it
wasn't a pun it was just kind of a game
that you lost that I'm just gonna bring
up because George would no I don't want
to anymore now that you're welcoming it
I really don't want to if you like
fought me like don't do it then oh it
doesn't solve its Polizzi it just yeah
just this you're too nice is what I was
saying yesterday one when nice people
star like ribbing at you those are the
most effective and most annoying kind of
like insults or not insults but but the
thing is like I've worked with Anish and
I've got dragged so much like I was
bullied literally so do you talk about
that I was bullied so should we talk
about just I'm trained I mean I've
become tough after that after all that
torture but it sounds like there are
some deep-seated emotional issues that
might be
[Laughter]
well nice III gone right ahead of sinks
yeah like you might've stick to the move
you should play in two seconds not 12
seconds because I'd retire you pump then
be fine you think I'm scared might be
five yes well I'm not so
queenside
okay white one the staredown because
black blinked d4 6100 by the way so yes
it was another pun know after the you
booed me so well you deserved it because
really good fat tuition is good at
exchanges now I know that but it's such
a it's so nerdy that pawn I think it
just I'm sorry that I only was once it
hot it's not gonna get better
don't get better by failure
so the silence hurts my ears so let's
see he plays d4 after long think I like
white no seafood go c4 actually we're
not allowed this iqp right I was thing
about Knight g4 in some lines but then
just group D 2 F 1 I yeah yeah we have
fun
so c4 just trying to get rid of it I
mean you could take on d4 as well but
Bishop c5 but I agree with you c4 just
ob6 see a game that typical move which I
said it's like too indecisive you know
like so I hear really you like I could
be no I don't like the iqp I'm just not
discriminating against the IQ Peas VIN
it okay
IQ peas or pawns to your masochist you
know you like some pudding yeah don't
judge me for my flaws judge me for my
strengths I don't have many of them but
they do exist every now and then this
doesn't look great for black I'm gonna
be honest with you f3 f3 and all just
Knight g4 business is wrong right you
take away the g4 square you take away
the e4 square you pretend you're a pawn
by pushing it the one thing that black
should try it somehow to make use of the
dark squares but just not possibly after
e95 would be the ideal situation but now
you're walking to a diagonal bishop on
it's probably not good
I would think White's position any day
yes I would also do the same again you
know so soft like why would you play b6
please seafood and you not close the
diagonal made much more sense right can
we try 95 here literally yeah there it
is see that I'm whispering to Tania meat
I you want me to play 95 and I would
love it if you had a 95 I would play 93
but 93 on my plate 96 and try to go to
have four I would blame out of life
leave me alone you're playing good moves
I mean I'm just trying to get some
squares and you're just trying to win my
pawn so I agree with you again
you win nine a 4 but to Bishop III check
6,200 oh that sounds like we're ready
for a pun well now you know the
benchmark is high a lot more okay fine
but would you put on their g6 red and c6
I know you like the knight on f6 and g6
but I've known I don't need food
actually to begin with well I would
either go to be five or eetu and get to
be four and block but pawn I'm with you
there but I do believe that blacks last
move knight c6 Knight g6 because you can
meet Knight g3 at night h4 taking away
the very important f5 Square sure
putting pressure on i-84 is very cool by
the way there is one book it's by I
think chess pattern recognition well it
shows that night on the edge is not
always bad that you can go to h4 and
then you know it controls so many square
and it stops like this G to pawn f3 pawn
you know it is both of them it's very
annoying I don't know how to say get
broad yeah I just said it again no
reason this just for the sake of just
showing off that I read books well I'm
proud of you
but rook t5 in private Sonia because
ever like a good move
you just attack attacking his knight on
f5 and if the knight takes and e3 you've
given me a passed pawn g4 b 5o is it
trap Oh No what c4 would you go seafood
or 93 I would play 93 but c4 is pretty
adventurous but c4 for six f5 and you
resigned
Oh a nice yes I missed that that's
really bad so Knight c3 this ET point is
still a little bit weak right yeah it
looks like a strength but it's actually
very easy to attack and much harder to
defend
Oh someone said that okay I'll tell it
later
38 maybe 95 repeat 1 e 2 e 2 94 i before
e
90 never yeah they have 3.0 this is true
not really well for black this is nice
I think he just missing one for I wonder
ticket tonight anyway zombie one rupee
one rupee 894 now nitrogen 93 looki -
yeah but you take on E - and then you
win with G flat one I&I touch five is
nice 9h Phi is nice because 1949 f3 to
keep you looking for
mm-hmm let's show that really quickly 94
93 rookie - rookie for rookie 46 go a 6
is 6
well 3 seconds 2 seconds wow this is no
time at all for white black before pawn
oh that king is in close yeah the boats
one is push the H Vaughn she blended a
600-foot whoa what taken King C 5 YC 4
why would you please see for yeah that
just helps you know when it gets to GD 3
King dude really
King King living in one of these trick -
that was tricky like if I have no
happening what's happening if I oh my
gosh she triggered upon you can just
don't trick yourself
wait she can't nothing keep no you don't
know how did this happen maybe 5 97
waitwhat don't ok she's trying to go for
the little wheel 96 96 let King be able
such a bad g5 disco g5g fine push the
g-man configs again night Michigan no
you need to push the Jeep on pain if7
what is happening tonight before Rose
winning don't give up your pawn g3o this
is been amazing I even have a best game
ever so the king is just going to you
know come this way to be a draw
oh this is the best game ever 94 Oh
metaphor would've been too good so would
you think that they deserve to draw this
game I don't know who deserve what but
we definitely deserve this entertainment
[Laughter]
that was unbelievable both their faces
let me be like oops and like just sorry
I just didn't see that business
themselves yeah they were just like I
don't know what happened there that was
honestly amazing so you know to be fair
to the players playing with mere seconds
on your clock in a very like nervous
event where you're you're playing for
hours on it it's very difficult so we're
laughing we're having a good time but
we've all made mistakes like that and
just to put it out there again that I've
missed meeting won twice in classical
games so I have the right to make fun
because you know I have me I've been in
in the worst position so what do you do
you have the right Robert have you miss
Mayton once then you don't have the
right okay I'm gonna I'm not gonna make
fun of amber make front of you how have
you miss me want what have you done this
how it's called talent well did we eat
I'm troubled no no we have just we full
your mouth in one game I was in time
trouble but the other game was just pure
talent
how old were you
I was I was an adult already okay so
your rating was pretty high
yeah I was twenty-six hundred what I was
trying to 600 plus so did you still win
the game presumably if you miss Mayton
one you're winning right no you didn't
win the game and I got meted I missed
I got mated in one I mean I missed my oh
you miss your pony's making one yes okay
I got maintained on the board so that's
more excusable because sometimes people
get tunnel vision and then they miss
their pawns plans but if you miss
checkmate a1 like you didn't check me at
your opponent when it was checked man 1
I would never forget
okay because I was in 400 you should
talk about the game yeah breath ah
you're gonna make a chess pawn you're
6464 or something something anyway this
game here White has a bishop black does
not the knight on c6 um can't really
move anywhere so I'm trying to think of
how you improve your pieces the 96 is
really the problematic piece for black
because white is gonna go rook c1 and
then if you move the Met away from c3
the nice sort of gets stuck on you say
you should be going known Lemmy's going
for some kind of attack here do you
think sighs I really don't like that
move you don't like trying to go for
rook g6 and check me as I said I'm bad
at that didn't you
previous conversation I just you know I
want you to be a good listener robot I'm
not great listener I just want you to
relive those great memories at us okay
yeah you are a good listener
when c4 is bad boy I think I would have
gone Queen f3 you know just cement
banking site but the thing is the rooks
somehow need to jump through the night
to g6 to actually attack you and if you
don't take my name it might come to f4
where it's a very good defender and not
to mention the c7 pawn is immediately
under threat so
what are you gonna do is black your eyes
the 9595 Quincy so 95 will be fine at f3
I live for tricks but there was night of
6 in the end through cat 6 Quincy 76 no
nobody's following what you're saying
but I'm gonna try anyway 95 what are you
saying 95 96 27 to 6 and young Queen e7
you know just for fun night if we can
get one Queen h3 and that's how the game
would end oh my gosh you are just you
and that is honestly that's way better
than anything I've seen so that was
awesome
that was pretty cool no Queen h3 you're
setting up tricks here I've watched you
do that blindfold tactic stuff where was
that with chest face or something where
you you know you did all those blindfold
tactics that was cool but what you just
show up is way cooler
thank you now Knight f3 g f2 queen it's
3 go if I don't get 6 just go for check
this know what this queen g4 sorry you
blunder checkmate one g7 checkmate what
am I gonna do with you actually can you
play c6 here and after rook d8 then
Knight f3 check yeah GF 2 Queen g5 yeah
oh I think this is what makes you a
super Jim it makes me a super not super
GM is that I see checkmate on one but I
don't see all the other things and then
you miss check me into one but you see
all the more difficult things so yeah
you know now after that I should not be
allowed to speak for one minute so you
know no no I don't want to go on a
monologue you know it's too difficult I
need you you just want to hear me say
that this is you rebuilding your ego on
stream but c6 feels like the right music
yeah c6 rook c5 b6
maybe Brooke d6 or something
why is he taking so much time at NES
thought for he thought for like one
minute and a half
g6 King f1 I like King f1 yep
it's a very smart move you're staying at
any discoveries removing yourself from a
pin and what can black even do here
you're kind of tied down do you think
it'll be it no yep
yeah wrong more
yeah you didn't wanna go he won't show
you six in back that's not ideal it
would be one go
yeah bring your other Runyan I like that
move - I will not move the night now
just sing just sing okay I not been IG 6
whatever f 4 I will avoid embarrassment
no I have for the participants amazed -
yeah too much
I want you to blunder main one again
that was pretty awesome
that's what I'm saying I'll not move the
night okay so let's see takes at 4:00 I
just left six just left six right f6
shuts down this whole diagonal that's
important say an f4 is a weakening moves
I probably have four should not be
played
wait what about cleanup for instead of a
queen bee for trading the Queen Johnny X
the New Zealand square yeah that's
really Oh
windy fall backward Queen h4 what you
gonna meet Mort I heard you
you said Queen d4 back he's a queen d
for forgetting the Queen's except to
mate did it oh my gosh Wendy T you're
the best thank you
you're absolutely the best
you should have six oh that's not a
point you want to wander because now
Bishop retreats and there's permanently
checkmating ideas so edge fold it just
lost its lost but it's not easy when you
have four seconds at age five that's a
risky move to I mean two seconds two
seconds
Oh Queen eight I like it don't watch
everyone check in f3 Queen f3 yeah
becoming a five we should be fresh
before is nice
you should be four wait don't fly
mission before and before time no single
time search and Bishop before actually
was holding like I'm not saying white
should not eventually lose but for the
time being especially in a bullet game
this would be forced out black threads
you know what happened just to justify
you will I was not allowed to tell my
pun and you're good after that and they
just threw me off completely
that's why I missed all the meeting one
all right you're making me ass you make
me beg can you please give me another
pun
I've been waiting because I have really
bad ones and I don't know what I'll miss
next but can you just give me a pond
yeah it's again a well-known pun I think
it's pretty common okay okay
why did no one apply at Kappa Blancas
company
because he had no opening oh my gosh oh
my gosh it extra is kind of good I like
that one I never heard it before if I
had heard it that way it's not mine it's
not mine it's a friend of Mines so do
you have any puns yourself or you're
just all recycled material you know all
of my points now will be from my friends
so if you know if it's a bad one
they'll get the credit enemies so are
the puns really I mean that you are the
friend just you like you're pretending
to be your own friend yes it's my like
watcher me you know okay I'm I prove so
I'm kidding it's really by a friend of
mine you have the best friends in the
world Tanya needs you to be a better
friend to her because she's spending 40
seconds yeah I mean it were eight and a
half and two and a half you have this
line you know I like the opening choices
ladies using really putting the pressure
right from the beginning yeah he's given
coupon but what he's gained for the pond
is very nice little pieces although I
think Quincy food is not the move Bishop
as far as the moves right I actually
enjoy news so a t-coil I had a game
against Creek or Mecca tarean in this
line many many many years ago in the air
flat open and I had the white side and
we played a position like this but right
now this is not looking super familiar
with the is you're back on CA toe know
what's going on here
so what should wait to take on d5 by
Brooke d1 94 or 94 is also looking good
but 94 and what point can i play them
with a g6 I don't want to but I feel
like g6 tonight at 6 check just wolf
yeah there's no King g7 would be one
wait hang your own mission b6 right
where you're creating energy for no no I
mean in the current position
oh sorry sorry and I'm just so you you
love this soon yeah I know I know
okay so what move here are you
suggesting I'm to show you six yeah
looks good oh is that we ship at six
let alone six Morris would go Bishop at
six and say hello but Jesus and now
you've taken a fair take on a five
yeah but then this is ninety five in the
end you know I've moved the Queen and
then you know a troop will be hanging
yeah here AC for weakness but this
bishops III well I can also just give
you that rook I don't know no I can't
you take what the Queen ninety-five and
then oh you're too good I quit
Oh we'd be great so 95 now okay doesn't
matter
she has been played as getting excited
for know you're gonna go full sack town
d5 yeah yeah yeah something like that
we never know is not in the spirit of
the position no it's not black feels
like she's coordinated well because that
Knights coming right to you five and
once that happened as black is just okay
develop 96 night of three is a Czech
Queen otherwise it would work but
Queenie tooth did you know all the
pieces were on the kingside and now
black has develop and white has just
been pushed back so tan I so needs to
win this game
she needs to convert the winning
position she has got chances but she is
not capitalized on I think that's what
has gone wrong I agree this is like
Bishop g4 here alright now Bishop c4
yeah this is good no yep inside like I
like forcing f3 there something about
blunting this Bishop on g2 felt
promising when here just Queen c7 then
there's a building you would play c5
year
is there some kind of discovery not
really okay now that you said discovery
okay when you're right see if I'm scared
pun of what you're gonna say okay so
what is the favorite strategy of a
person who has visited a bank for the
first time
discovered check something Jen yeah nice
you led me to it yeah I mean you just
are a man with limitless puns I don't
know how you do it but you do it see
five just push this pawn you're up and
Fon c5
negative three oh I wanted to go Queen
c6 but I blunder it so let me show
everybody my blunder I think yes please
do I ran but I lost a piece on e5 I
thought I was pinning your piece but I
said I'm just losing a piece so go me
blundering things everywhere ignore me
I don't deserve friends with puns or
anything like that you know if Danny was
here he would really appreciate all the
puns I will feed you but the thing is I
appreciate the puns you know I really
have enjoyed you don't like it yeah I
mean it's just I need to let you know
that not all your puns are good because
if they're all good that means none of
them are good yeah sorry I know so like
if if it's all good then you don't
improve right and I know that you're
working very hard to improve not just
your chess game but your pong game wait
that was a good move Neji 696 Queen c6
would you go for this 92 for yea GF for
now Queen G for chair give me all that
yeah yeah but King moves if you think
I'm scared you very Gujarati you're very
very right it's not only 10 seconds 2598
you need to we need to go steal their
phone
so once again that should win this like
Chinese not a good amount of time she
blend this one bond Oh Queen CAG Queen
a7 rookie one take take on c3 your five
pawns 63 yeah take on c3 then night f2
eb-5 right Knight g5 95 we need we need
nothing nothing to worry about
yeah Queenie was ever in the move but
this is still no I think it's gonna be
draw see I thought before b3 b2 was the
way to go I think she should try to flag
now she should really go for the flag
yep
krazy-8 2526 g6g see there's nothing
yeah Queenie six is nice
now c4 go for it FC three we need five
we need to check that's even better
see - yeah she played well this queenie
66 is i am over nice shimmer extremely
well yeah after after giving the beef up
on she started to play well maja she
needed to not have such a good position
before playing extremely well is what
you get
and we have five and a half minutes left
of the three minute Parshin so what's
the score now eight and a half three and
a half so a five-point lead for levy
that's not good news for time machines
to get this victory goes again that you
know and this line he has been doing
well she should change up something you
know go for p1e4 kind of setup right yep
what do you think yeah queasy chewy for
something with ephors
she's pleased the same one rupee one
where she got was you know with this
b-52 if you remember yeah I remember
yeah I'm for sure remember why I was
trying to go over k3 and all that you
didn't like it no everyone doesn't make
sense if I was anyways a move which
black wants to play so everyone doesn't
make sense well she's gone for before
and she stopped these 94 after after all
the moves I suggested someone else is
with it really high rated then yes no
you're not nobody knows the answer is
yes he is but in terms of having I
actually don't know anything I'm high
reading yard say may be unfriendly I'm
higher rated than you are or beard
growth I'm definitely higher than you
are true is that about it and give that
to you and I think that's it it's all I
got yeah Wow my life is sad
anyway exposition takes takes I go g5f
for I'm gonna go see five and then my
knight can't get to see four so that's
pretty sad yeah g5 c 504 yes you should
really catch
she needs to really get this get on the
street go through three games at least
well here is g5 and f4 is next you're
right it's just the pawns are just
pushing themselves down the board and
white doesn't have any real counter play
on the queenside you're too slow is
something that my voice is a coin is it
your voice is echoing I wish it were
echoing okay it's all that time okay you
sound good to me but if I did hear an
echo that would that would be nice as
well so it's your choice I'm open but F
for played Bishop f5 is the move that's
expiration is so good
Queen e8 2 H 5 is the idea you want
I thought it'll get you no no no no I
was making a point saying at first you
have to deal with the rook and then you
do this other stuff wow you think so
lowly of me as breathing for the time so
I think it's the last game or like last
five minutes
yes lasts a few minutes section yep
I like White's position now because once
c5 happens there's 95 discovery ideas
along the diagonal and it feels like
we're c5 Knight d5 work a1 stuff because
of whites now first to the initiative
yeah I would go Queen e8 putting on a
chip and I'll forget about my Queen side
just go quindi eight move the King g4 92
here comes the Knight to c4 I mentioned
a long time ago so you're also gonna be
44 yeah you know that's how you like
move chief food kind of helps white
right because black doesn't actually
have an attack at least not right now
yeah you like Gossage 5 okay now it's
getting interesting
it's now it's getting interesting so
might be five you would play when I'd be
five yeah yeah 95 hit c7 see if you deal
with that and then you're gonna okay
wrong move order but it's probably still
good yeah but 95 Queen is six now Oh
90 cent we need to be sure about this
one does it use the Queen yeah you're
Amish lost the queen I present you Queen
b6 after Knights okay 94 doesn't matter
so now you can click win d8 h 4 is next
yeah but H 4 is not that scary because
even if you take a couple time dingy fil
a Queen f6 go queen of 694 takes takes
uff G ah you're a sneaky guy don't go
check my F takes G Queen up to check and
then Queen takes e2 and yeah
and now if you don't go an ID for I left
3 myself and that should be crushing to
black is back lack is back but I don't
agree that it's crushing
but I agree with you people are loving
Robert has in the chat I just wanted to
put that out there loving me yeah you're
winning load of love thank you
you know I presume you're speechless I
you should compliment me I'm not used to
the compliment and then I don't know
what to say it reminds me of Danny like
I saw this stream on like with Ali and
Ali yeah and whenever our Ian was
freezing Danny used to look at the side
and ask really good yeah he was that
funny I mean the thing is I don't you
know I don't need the approval but then
when I get it I'm sorry I don't know
what to say you don't know what to do
yeah yeah I'm speechless this does not
look good for what the f to pawn is a
big issue H for any moment can still be
good the one thing that time is hoping
for is a night landing on e4 if then I
can get c4 then Queen c2 right so yeah
sorry to stop no no you're you're right
to bring that up because now that the
night gets on e4 that's a very good
defensive piece I'd anyway that's
survived a we should be photos a good
move she played well that'd be really
good very good for us really good move
yeah it was really good move yep let's
see so Knight takes after
I thought that he was gonna do this
because is really nothing why can do on
the King sir anymore and how do you
defend your King side now 23 right white
should just be queen d3 get ya see place
23 is there gonna be like Bishop h6 and
oh you're turning they tasty success no
no no no yeah at some point you're
throwing you what time travel in 80
seconds
it's not easy to come up with a move for
black really because you're so focused
in the attack that you know it's equate
what okay just a move its addendum move
look at seven
yeah what are like like a faint
something c1h three we should be three
put the bishop on need three yes
protect the f2 on it 1986 was a threat
no that one no no where you're
exchanging Queens looks again not ideal
but these end games still f3 play after
hit some play no she wants with the
night of 694 so right
she wants it all we should be 7f three
looks okay lady sees but it's clever it
King H 2 and F 3 here we go okay not bad
actually this was super high schools
yeah kingi for yep Bishop g5 any Bishop
do you find there it is use it like a
nickel that's what I've realized today
takes King a5 King e6 oh he's eating of
six King f6 and here comes the Jeep on
g4 nice very nice Technium in this game
I must admit this has been a fantastic
showing by Tonya 94 how can I get ready
nice technique again
I'm mesmerised that those are good good
toilet and this is the best way to end
the three-minute portion because that
technique was fire like if we just go
back in time to right and it was will go
to a break shortly after this but when
she went Bishop afford we were praising
this move because she's trying to land
her knight on e4 and then you know
protect the f2 pawn and she was able to
make this happen John Queen c2 here
trying to trade bishops and they give
his knight here and that's what exactly
what happened the night came before it
and then she traded Queens then she made
his great 94 move threatening Knight of
6 check and then when rook c3 trading
the rooks off in the one in game
fantastic was the last official game
right off three-minute section it was
not wrong okay so now you're 25 minutes
of bullet and you're gonna happen
anything can happen I would say levy is
the favorite just because he's the
experience but Tonya has actually proven
herself very capable just when those
critical last seconds she's been
struggling
okay so we'll be back in two minutes
yeah you know I would normally trust you
to be like be like we'll be right back
guys everybody stay where you are and if
we still have six thousand viewers I'll
tell a pun but I'll say it for you stay
right where you are if we still have
this viewership we'll get a pun from
video Gujarati when we return
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and after that brief break we are back
with the bullet portion of coming
between levy Rosman
and Tanya such dev and just to show
everybody the full bracket John
Bartholomew has made his way into the
second round after a dominating
performance by score against David for
us but David was playing so much better
chest and that score indicates and did
it as you look through the bracket here
any names to look out for like how
familiar familiar are you with these
players
I think Alina as I said I know her quite
well and she's a very strong player and
she played Christoph right tomorrow
yep and then a great shot yeah I think I
know most of I think I know almost all
of them this is a very kind of American
Century she wants you're looking forward
to really the most oh I mean come on
it's Teddy Coleman versus Danny wrench
so Teddy Cota's is one of my best
friends on the planet I'm actually gonna
be the best man at his wedding
so like guys all my best friends in the
world and Danny wrench is my partner in
crime where do all my commentary with
and whose puns I ignore so that of
course is the match I'm looking forward
to the most but also I mean there are so
many good match you're on as a Tom
Seavers Gretch I do you think it's
underrated matchup and on the other side
has Elizabeth pets against they're
supposed to be a close one yeah yeah
because this one people may not know it
because Ana doesn't play as much online
blitz but she is a fantastic blitz
player she's really really strong mm-hmm
and well we have you know the next match
is tomorrow but before we get to the
future matches of course we have to
finish today's and I'm ready for this
bullet portion biddat what are your
predictions for this time segment coming
up
I think so considering the score it's
four points yeah that's a lot to cover
up and I think levy will win the match
but in bullet section
[Music]
he'll have one or two points Lee that's
what I see okay so in the end it will be
like a five-point difference or six
point difference okay so you have Lee in
Levy's board skills I mean he's just
very experienced he's a very strong
bullet player not just for an iron but
for anybody on this literally you know
in the last few games Tonya like in the
last game she played so well
yeah this technique when she gets simple
positions she's playing really well so
if she gets that you know why doll this
Dutch complex play really simple chairs
then she still has a chance because she
was very good in this game I agree I
mean if she gets a comfortable position
in the opening she's shown that she can
play with a very high class and play it
quickly that's really the essential
thing is she's in some critical moments
in time trouble she hasn't been able to
play her best stuff but here we go we
have liftoff we have bullet and we have
a position that should be very nice I'm
not changing it up that's very strange
well we would prefer if they had a new
opening in every single game but
sometimes people stick to the repertoire
yeah and she's gonna throw in an a3 I'm
guessing to stop any before yeah I was
gonna say she's gonna throw an 83 to
stop that but she did 865 go c5 play for
pigs do six tricks are 40 fights and for
vidit they see five don't take it
because in the bishop age to check just
there we go rookie one CD yeah CD Queen
d4 at least you can continue
so be three now okay only two is good
typing it fights with the like you fight
so good we should be it just just play
for the initiative but the problem is
you're losing p7 and that's it and no I
don't get CD okay you don't care and I
don't care but maybe Lily was I mean I
think the position once it doesn't get
CD you're winning back at the pond
it's true you're right I must admit
you're right again
95 yeah 94 just go like with tonight at
4-4 no nightly for what it was like a p4
is what you went all sorry yeah but she
took on d4 so I guess tonight DF D 2 F 3
and 1993 Bishop g5 it should be 5 just
ok 5 this is also ok yeah she's at 1 5
yeah 95 Oh Knight f3 Queen after yeah
and then e 5 no Knight of three you have
ID oh okay she seemed more tax than I am
look at that and you get the time
difference for bullet that's a lot
yup she was blitzing out she's just been
blitzing up
sorry video she was gonna take on b8
take on 87 and push her upon just like
what you'll get in yeah give up the b2
pompe take the a pawn and just like push
my a pond on the board
well I like what she is doing just
playing fast doesn't matter what like
moves just chilling decent moves
throughout so she has been playing well
good before let go with your instincts
here we should be for f3 and yeah just
ratings yeah 93 Scott play the first
move which comes to your mind that's the
best strategy in bullet yep just like 95
96 96 Brendan I did okay b5 no Bishop c4
is not good
nice no her piece is going back there
she's still doing totally fine she's up
a lot in the clock rook d1 is good
nicely for back spring and I really love
which she spring Bishop d6 was awesome
yeah be shaken up d6
oh that dosoo
yeah she had it she was playing
brilliantly bishop da we should be it oh
man
she's still up a lot of time but
unfortunately she's just down pieces
king of one
I would just maybe ships if I'd be
should be six you know more layer of
course
this is it hurts yeah Brooke 8786 just
do it
can't think twice here doesn't melt it
in town hasten your feet okay doesn't
matter anything is living listen well
everything is winning but when you have
three seconds left you know sometimes
you make a bad pre-move or bad things
happen to good people sometimes
gee philosopher Robert for you I do my
best
Brooksie seven king at six doesn't
matter no yeah
now it's tuition meet 3b - yeah that's
that's a nice classy finish there and
get a queen you bring your robe back day
one you win the a sex bomb yeah a night
seafood was the turning point of us it's
sad because she had so much time and
then she followed your advice of making
the first move that came to mind so I
blame you for that one
I don't like said that leaf and credit
levy because you know he only had five
seconds left but he found that tactical
resource at a critical moment she pinned
herself but he did find it yeah right
now we should be fine quickly you know
look at this edge for this now in
complete blitz mode bullet mode sorry
and he doesn't moving much more crit 93
93 he'll go 93 no 94 a 690 fine I'll
play six Oh
b6 yeah I don't understand that move
assets no castles only move move Oh King
d8 rook F a I guess but have a quick G
says can she Sagar Queen Queen D 6
Oh Queen b6 was such a cool move like
that although it doesn't work but I love
the move well she could've set it up
instead but she would has entered this
position which somehow is not dead lost
but it looks like it should be
Castle no castle means I guess he's
worried about hanging the a to bow to a
six yep
tiny it's kind of working our way out of
this
do you think she's going to survive this
game did it yeah
King season and is very safe already
soon it's just either short my goodness
it just our short sightedness that we
did not see this that King is really
different c7 yeah so she saw it off she
ran her king away and now play it looks
really good on c7 seafood not take on e5
go oh that was the exact to be five but
Dean is sacrificing pieces hard is
particularly sacrificing pieces
appreciating beam up on time by the way
15 GLD seconds something like that just
rotates F take CA yeah I don't get to
see it important don't hang your a
six-point b5
if I push him baby beef I see Ford oh
now I don't like b5 before go open it up
yeah as I said b5 king b6 man I was
hoping for five ice this is turning 76
it's gonna happen King to six it's gonna
happen I'm assessing out of desire yes
like most things in life King be a light
screen take take the pawn on c4 take
much with you Knight takes levy sir
yeah 27 Oh what should be said King b6
okay g4 and that something happened no
break left
you know King is really good on b6 now
FIA for might be that's cool take it in
[ __ ] a7 this is so much fun this is
ridiculous this game is epic
Oh Queen g4 is a good move try and trade
those Queens Bishop h6 oh hey what is
happening a truce to lambda part it's
just like it she took all cuz big Queen
D 495 there is v7 like know what 35 rook
t5 is it
don't be system in meat or Brooke before
me holy moly holy moly
this is too much going on here so after
every game we take a pause for like 10
seconds to recover we need it but it's
also really amusing because we're being
accused by just 1 or 2 people of being
biased for Tanya but this happens
literally every single match when
somebody is behind in the match you end
up rooting for the person to like get
more points because it's more if you
want to close match we're going to close
my arm that was crazy though
let me found some really cool tactics
first at night bring a Knight to c3 and
then play yeah and you just would before
ya freak related to him like going in
this bullet more than it's fun so what's
going on here just take on e4 we need
for finally she goes for the e4 break
yep and I have [ __ ] systems playing
Quincy to agree best square for the
Queen does it retreat there it is
and it's something like Glen might try
for c5 but yeah everybody clean d3
you're not getting C fireman
I think White's position little d1 a
little bit extra space you know yep
this should be four that's surprising
choice
it's funny because you often do want
your bishop on the diagonal fighting off
the light square bishop but on e4 it's a
very iffy spot what that doesn't work
because the bish was protected by the
pawn on d5 now yeah no I think it's nowt
a little more yeah it's clearly a tilt
move it's like you build up all these
great positions and you can't win them
so you know there's nothing's going
right so you might as well just keep
trying random things
and black is now up upon and as a better
position
yeah worst kind of combination
so take some G to Quincy 7 9 94 yeah
or 94 this Queen f4 so yeah that's why I
wanted to play Quincy zone but the new
93 so the night coming also she's up on
time so all this she needs to convert
this one 93 93 quite quickly 94 and then
Bishop f2o your devious queen bee - then
I'm not linked we should have to just
sing just sing I think you're just going
to be too destructive no I'm not letting
mr. website Bishop f0 come on all right
now she's gonna try to take the bishop
or not another pin
that's a good move f3 like actually it's
surprising and I can only go to f6 you
take it now both sides have bad pawns Oh
black is up the pawn on this before look
before before would have VD to run that
King away okay that's a nice move okay
play b6 and play brook h2 and just win
this Knight takes c6 okay
it's too many weaknesses yeah look it's
a good African - but levy isn't playing
to wellness that's five strange move I
think he's trying to take away the e4
square from her King okay look at that
that was great decision to just take
away this square watch out for some at
night of six chickens if the night get
step six blocks checkmate okay now
anymore ninety-five kind of lost tooth
red black kind of taken a look at 490
383 oh look at Shh
183 what's happening I don't know donors
become critical that's complete collapse
from group everyone okay now we're just
in before 2400 King before day 25 white
would have won this is crazy
wait what TV - okay she's still gonna
hold because they're double F pawns but
this is this has been wild c8
King a for King back to three that's
called and as they say you know
Grandmaster go and this will be an IM
draw it's definitely not a GM draw it's
in the title of the event c6 hope that
your opponent blunders no now it's
levees it's still the c5 pawn rook c8
King be central different
no you still playing for win Oh Tania is
one second ones actually check back she
you might get flagged I was feeling come
on five O king a five he kicking a five
next go
Oh take them yeah king of five rook c8
between it's very annoying but still
it's a draw yeah kingi 323 yen oh my
gosh dang it all the pawn she got it she
just got there in time
oh my god scored the lowest in this
predict the move did you see that though
she defend so she could pre move the
next one that was really smart
you know he goes don't see it yeah I
know the King rules that said he's
trying to end the match because I might
time today yeah makes sense make sense
make sense
we're gonna see 40 more moves of rook
versus rook
ah man if I was alright I would get this
I mean nobody wants to see that we just
talked about how you being happy makes
everybody happy so I don't want to see
you okay
six thousand five hundred
thank you everyone who have joined in
yeah we want you we want another poem I
already don't like for ya but we want
another pun
actually save it up for another time
yeah yeah well let you rest are we
really looking at rook and king versus
rook and king should we analyze this no
just type grapes just have grapes I
don't have grapes I have I have all the
wrath but none of the grapes
okay five you learn I think it's very
tough to come back from this this bigger
deficit yeah six points yeah
is it like you know the more you win you
get like the higher percentage of the
prize money of the match yeah so it's
the prizes by win percentage I'd stood
by one
so it's a queen on g4 I turn my head
away and there's a queen on g4 it looks
like a normal type position but the
Queen keeps getting out of the box
6,600
just saying you keep talking about the
number of people but you don't mention
puns it's not deleted now night before
default
I like blacks position you like your
eyes yeah night before and d4 yeah okay
but does but doesn't happen
everything was good for black here
because white went all-in on the sort of
French like attack but when you fee and
keto it turns to be tends to be a bad
situation for wife because the knight
comes to be for your [ __ ] mom because
she's not doing anything and then d4 as
you said oh she's an open the kingside
g6 nice it's practical easy moves and
you know what take on e5 also not now
yeah I see you're saying sack a piece
there it looks pretty interesting yeah
this is like is like huge time I'd
wonder if she speaks so fast she knows
these French oh vegetables blender yep
there's a piece he sees it yeah yeah
he's like oh they're guys do like that
there is you know like a camera where
you can see the players
makes so much fun yeah because you can
see them be very sad no no the
expression you know if you like I love
how you agree with me because like
thinking I would say something nice when
I said something not nice no no no it's
not what I'm saying
also this is a perfect position for levy
to waste time because even though blacks
appearance and winning I don't know why
I lack closed it yeah I don't know why
black closed it he six starts the night
okay I
yeah that's not good Brooke 65 and like
white is turning Iran
okay well now it's still it'll be five
still look defies my positioning for
displaying for the crowd getting
opposition on us
okay I think what's Loomis's
okay black was just up a peaceful
nothing levees gonna win this game he's
four seconds though
IIIi agree lucky one rook e8 located lat
when's peace
no that was 27 really located quick
Voltron quintic CA and when mission was
on h5 Oh gotcha
96 clear a six or how is black of a
piece again 96 check what I'm so
confused but everything that's happened
in this game
King bee 697 okay this is awesome it
exceeds do you know you should take
folks
a bit I'm secret for you my head you
know King visits King e6 a day
appointment push my head hurts covering
these bullet games is a whirlwind and a
half
oh gosh which is six
Brooke takes a six take a six I guess
I'll take it next rookie three finally
take that c3 pawn
King d6r up d3
okay that's also good check okay black
is now just winning a six
no gift no look it
okay 1 C 3 C 3 now
oh man c3 check King d6 next key number
6a 696 know what six lights you for
still okay okay the Viking see 593 day
300 the King was there for the fork it
who gets to I'll do with this now with
like actually it's not easy put in this
like John Wayne is drawn oh god oh god
oh pretty nice now I need to draw
997 but tb5 is a draw oh boy
you know and see that he offered the
draw white offered to draw and I need it
like she probably didn't say we're just
moving okay yeah Luke b5 Hey I'm
recording a video yeah plain can you
explain that game to me
okay thank you
um I'm at a loss because I can't explain
that there was like three blunders piece
blunders and then pork and then draw and
everything is you know there is you
cannot expect an answer for everything
that was realized he takes a four winds
of at least one pond
but what I was gonna say is that bullet
is really difficult and when I play
bullet I play tons of terrible moves so
it's not like you know I Oh
Queen takes a one that's a work yeah but
where's game it's not like either buster
buzzes when we play bullet the same
mistakes kind of happen where we blunder
pieces away it's very tough and yeah I'm
moving in the instant but when you're up
it's always easier to like secure and
permanent it doesn't matter what game it
is like any game even if it's well
championship candidates whatever it is
it's always easier to sit and comment it
then there's no responsibility in terms
of the moves if I blunder east I just
take the move back yeah I mean I miss
meeting Duke twice during the show you
also miss me so I'm making one I'm
saying sorry meeting one twice you miss
made one so many times that you just
forgot that who lost the count I lost
the count um no but it just it's tough
and I feel for Tanya it's becoming a bit
of a rout in a Levy's favor but as we've
seen throughout this match frizzy think
about how few games we've seen this is
game 19 if I'm not mistaken yesterday we
had 26 games so that's how close these
games have been where they're going down
to the wire pretty much every single
time how many games yesterday 26 okay
let's fight the Lord and how many how
much time is left three minutes three
minutes yeah okay yep so be sure before
95 at six 94 oh go go go at six on the
move
it's exist don't blunder queen at seven
okay so what do you want count I think
it's level so 94 we should be seven wow
it is love let's so well you know Angley
six lon
oh yeah so you're gonna do we should be
something
hey what to do 97 go write a five I
don't know yeah I don't know I make
sense now so should be three is very
nasty we should be three Bishop d6 yeah
yeah you should have gone at least I'm
still like these six we should be three
worst area very unpleasant take and I
you know the opening choices again good
opening Josie is going for the
initiative when it's playing although
it's the tire is clearly misses his
favor so yep when things are going good
not get no
that was yeah I turn my head and I did I
turned my head for a second did it like
look at the chat and then a rook was
gone
so yeah yeah it's just like a day yeah
it's so it's a bad bad things are not
going well yeah
doo-doo-doo-doo odo yeah anyway so right
now we see the double pawns for white
levy is just gonna pile up pressure on
them play ok those go 96 95 at some
moment but he said she's Knight to d7
[Music]
and now is like it's such a comfortable
position because usually in exchange for
these double pawns you had a very quick
initiative but here you don't have that
which is have double bonds
[Music]
Knight g5 I was not way to move weight
rupee one 9ig 592 is the passive version
of 95 like I think that's what I noticed
you know she has this instinct of bling
like very solid she will not go for the
most decisive options that's the feeling
I got and I saw the games yeah I think
you're ready kind of shied away from
more concrete lines in favor playing
like a calm or move but sometimes the
position really requires that you play
in that moment rather than saving up for
later so now 57 and doubled adults
gopher
okay so that the a for pawn now is on a
targeted square so if the Queen moves
from C to you lose a four and the CC
pawns are still kind of weak so levy has
played this one perfectly thus far I
think we see only two more games right I
think no this is the last one this is
the last one yeah
yeah so I think that so you know that's
what it makes the difference she was
getting good positions but she didn't
have the practice for this kind of
format of playing online and from my
experience I think it makes a big
difference like some people who are used
to it you know see first of all a 2d
board and then having the small skills
and playing under like time pressure not
making fewer mistakes under time
pressure all of this it all comes your
cells practice really matters use of
very rarely play so many games in a row
or that's them in some ways the problem
in the sec is that when you lose a game
you don't get a five-minute break
you got to play their next game right
away and you know when things go bad
sometimes they look really drift that's
what happened today
poor Tanya
so right now levees and movies can't go
after the g3 pond there it is and yeah
levees the kind of that I think it was
for a direct attack is that you grow pre
you know that kind of stuff he likes to
play that's what I've noticed black we'd
like to go dutch for example i would
have taken on e2 and gone to g4 and
played that endgame but he wants to keep
the queen's yeah he wants to go for
checkmate f4 f4 look f3 24
FG yep FG and H for pawn at the very
least is okay you can take it now he
goes for the hanging game okay yeah it's
lost yeah rook AG for there it is to
running me and then if you take take
here comes the Brooklyn third all the
bonds are win rookie three or not
Luke g2 new jutsu is it all over g2 g2
to g4 okay so still it was winning but
who thought it was a nice trick to try
you know yeah I just try to blockade and
say yeah but nobody I think that'll see
six breaks right right you go here play
six but we had fun
unfortunately this one came to a end
where the match is over we've gotta take
a quick break and we return well the
interview with both players so look
forward to that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Tania and Levy thank you so much for
joining us I know that was an exhausting
match and a fun one for us and the fans
congratulations shoot levy Tania
unfortunate that one didn't go your way
what do you think you could have changed
or done differently that would have made
the result a little bit better for you I
think I think my chances were better and
the five-minute limit Ramona and I think
I especially in the five minute I think
in the beginning dispositions that I'm
in stuff I what would make it better is
definitely more blitz practice and more
bullet practice I think it's completely
a different it's a different animal from
my classical play and I think it's a lot
to do with time and with your time
management and I think I need I need to
work on that so in the one minute in the
bullet I had absolutely no chance I mean
even a few positions through games where
I had a good position and I was even up
one time I ended up messing it up so
adding the first few games of the five
minute is where I had the best Johnson
probably should have capitalized on that
oh sorry I didn't know if I was supposed
to a second no I mean I definitely agree
I think the match was far far closer
than the score reflects unlike yesterday
that that score was very very reflective
of the difference of skills no friends
David
I felt like Tonya was like better in
probably 75% of the positions that we
were playing and I was very slow I think
I was just a little bit luckier but real
quick before you guys ask another
question I just want to give a shout out
to my mom because it's her birthday and
I said I would win for her and happy
birthday mom you're the best hope you're
healthy love you okay guys no questions
definitely your turn to ask a question
so what do you think was the turning
point like I think at some point the
score was five and a half two and a half
and Tonya was like winning the game like
almost but that game she lost from good
pushing I think that was the turning
point because if she would have won so
what do you think according to you was
the turning point where it started to
drift away for you Tonya played so many
games was kind of hard to say right now
but Vidya I I think I think a couple of
the five-minute games which were better
for me and which went badly wasn't I
think just one it was quite a few of
them yeah so it's kind of hard to point
out but I think even going into the
three minutes segment I still like was
feeling that okay fine you know even
though I lost more games in the five
minutes in considering the positions I
got and the way I was playing I thought
that I would be I would be able to fight
back and it's far from over but I think
I think losing I think it's when we went
to one minute and I was already down a
lot on the score that I felt it's going
to be harder to come back but then one
minute anything can happen but I I did
have an idea that levy is has played a
lot of bullet and he is a strong bullet
now and I did not have as much practice
and that's something that I hope I can
improve on and put up a better fight
next and levy and your end before the
show began we're talking and you were
commending time for being such a solid
player and you chose the Dutch defense
so were you purposely trying to get sort
of tactical or more imbalance positions
yeah you know there was this question
yesterday it said both John and David
about whether or not they prepared and
both of them were like I'm too busy at
other things to do and um I found that
hilarious because like when I was
preparing I mean you know preparing we
look at each other's openings if how
much blitz and bullet experience we have
it cetera and I just noticed that like
III have to stop preparing because I was
just making me sad seeing how much
better of a classical player Tonya's
than me like all these like really solid
games against 2625 like hiring players I
was like you know what I'm I'm just
gonna play this you know if she stays
consistent which pretty much did happen
throughout the match I'll try to get
like attacks in the Queens gambit
accepted if we go for that variation
I'll just play the Dutch I felt like the
Dutch positions that one were pretty
promising and imbalanced and that's
probably where things favored me if
anywhere but most of the match was
probably decided within the last you
know 15 seconds per player frankly like
yeah it was extremely draining
emotionally yeah YouTube played 20 games
whereas yesterday did mattress to 26
games so clearly the games were taking
longer and they're much more down to the
wire and Tonya I mean you mentioned how
more bullet practice would benefit you
it did we felt like there are many 50/50
games where in mutual time trouble
they're just you know blunders that you
wouldn't normally see so is that really
what you came down to not just in the
bullet portion of the time control but
also just in general the waning seconds
we're doing you no favors I never quite
a few games I just wear my where I just
left my room just like that and it
didn't happen once I didn't happen a
couple of times in like reasonable
position
yeah like Lobby was saying I think it
came down to to the last few seconds in
which he was too fast too strong I think
that was one game which was really nice
very the black head pawns on g4 h3 and
then you exchanged everything no you're
a king you took the pawn on h3 with the
king went to f7
just for g4 that was a nice gift I think
right before the bullet section
that was a much-needed like confidence
booth so yeah yeah that was a amazing
honestly yeah that game I mean I I knew
I had to regroup after that game because
it felt like my attack was stronger and
then I for some reason took on e4 and I
just I mean the bishop there was like
not so strong but in the night just
killed the whole attack music oh I think
for me the well I know I know they did
ask about like turning point very early
in the match no Tanya the game where it
was like in English I think the only
English of the matter I'm not mistaken
and so I sacked my rook in the corner
and like found that combo to win the c7
pawn trap denied in b3 I was like this
is the most genius thing I've ever done
there is no more peek and then you know
I had like four seconds versus 50 or
something I felt like if I had lost that
game then definitely 5-1 would have been
closer I think that was a 5-1 cavern
even though at this point yeah that game
was
well it was a great match indeed and
Levy had one final question for you
because now that you've moved on in the
bracket who do you want to play between
Teddy Coleman and Danny wrench uh well
probably want to go head to head with
Danny because well I don't know but as
of five minutes ago I actually thought
he was the favorite in that match but I
think it'll be fun
my position would be to make it open
microphone talk some trash embarrassed
Danny live in front of thousands of
people and you know show why 2gm
commentary is better Wow
well I like the words of confidence
thank you to you both it really was a
fantastic match Tonya again sorry didn't
go your way and Levy congratulations
you're moving on but everybody really
enjoyed it so thank you thank you thank
you you too thank you Congrats on the
back thank you well we just saw a
phenomenal fight between two stellar
players they have a lot of mutual
respect for one another it was a close
battle but only one player could move on
that is international master levy Graz
when the two seed by rating he showed
that when it came down to the wire he
hadn't going for him and so he moves on
the opposite side of the bracket from
the number one seed John Bartholomew so
did it as you look at the bracket we see
JB we see levy into the second round
how about Lawrence Trent I gotta ask you
about that match Laurens friend Briscoe
she could ski maybe you don't know coach
just so well but what are Lawrence's
chances in a field like this who is the
hydrogen they're about the same I think
coaches a little bit higher rated and I
mean I don't know what you're asking me
what do I feel about Lawrence trend and
have to sum it up in one minute so much
he's a very cool guy and for sure and
he's always like you know he takes jokes
on him well so that's a very good
quality not many people can do that so I
admire him for that and just wise I have
not seen him play for long so I'm
looking forward to it you know
yeah and coach here is a friend of mine
as is more and so I just you know I'm
just trying to get you to say
something controversial you've really
succeeded in pairing that threat so good
on you
but as I look across the bracket I'm
really excited for all these matchups
remind everybody the schedule the
actually continues tomorrow with Alina
Caplan skaia
taking on Christophsis lucky so that's
going to be another fun one you praised
Alina quite a bit throughout the show
today as probably the player most likely
to become a grandmaster she does have to
GM norms she's near 2500 rating she's
married to someone who's a little bit
good at chess I don't know if you've
heard of this guy for Tod check but it's
pretty good he only won the Isle of Man
2018 and is what you know it dragon like
you know would practice good stuff
please lot of chess online and I don't
remember
Alina playing so much so that's again an
important factor as we saw today in the
practice of playing online for sure
because as good as you can be over the
board if you're not practice online then
your mouth speed won't be really up to
par and so the matchups that we have
left on excited for every single one of
them I think that they can go really
either way we did see the favorites move
on convincingly
that's with John Bartholomew and Levy
rosin but I do think as we these matches
unfold we will see some upsets at least
by initial ranking but vidit as always
it's been an absolute pleasure having
you join me for commentary you know that
I greatly respect your chest and I'm way
too nice to you relative to how I am so
I think you understand your position
I still got booed so you did you got
good looks I love sleep well but there
were no there are no moments of silence
at least you can get that awkward
silence and I guess that's worse than
booing right because that's like
disappointment you know when you're
disappointed that's always the worst
feeling when you know you did something
wrong they're not angry at you but
they're giving you that well maybe you
shouldn't have done that you feel that
you know the pain yeah I really don't
want to make you feel bad but sometimes
I have to like I said it's a growing
experience and you and I are gonna be
teammates I know you're excited for that
that would be a big be a big match I
honestly hope we get all sorts of like
variance and we have some bughouse going
on I don't how are you a bug ass I'm
pretty good and you're pretty good
doesn't I mean I just I'm better than
you
that's does one but that's a low
schnitzel low bar so I play against my
opponent siren blaring speices okay well
you know I do appreciate that you can at
least be better than Danny at that I
don't know what we have in store for us
when we have that match but it's going
to be video Gujarati and I will be
taking on a nice giri and Danny wrench
I'm so pumped about that I've mentioned
like six times already but right now
we're gonna do bid everyone a farewell
enjoy yourself stay healthy stay safe
and keep enjoying the chest that's
brought to you by chest calm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]